...
May 18, FB14, Firebase
Overview,
2 p.m. PST.
PST....
...
May 18, FB14, Firebase
Overview,
2 p.m. PST.
PST....
have to do is copy and paste
these two lines of code in bold
to get the basic integration
started.  You import and just
configure it.  And boom, you're
done.
[ Applause ]
So let's switch back to the
slide.  And so, the two steps
that you just saw were very
quick way to get started with
the basic integration and that
basic integration gets you --
that basic integration gets you
Firebase Analytics.  Firebase
Analytics is a brand new product
built from ground up from our
experience in running Google
Analytics.  Except it is
designed specifically for unique
needs of mobile apps.  Instead
of focusing on sessions and
pages, it is eventcentric and
usercentric.  And being the
heart of the Firebase product
suite it connects across all
Firebase features.  And most
importantly, it is free and
unlimited.  Let's switch back to
the demo and I'll show you what
this is like.
I'm going to show you a
production called Bingo Blast.
Bingo Blast you can imagine is a
bingo game available on Android
and iOS so now we are back to
the console and you see these
apps I have.  I have my
production app on Android and
production app in iOS and
Analytics populated.  Let me
drill into Firebase Analytics
for this iOS app.  So the main
view for Firebase Analytics is
this dashboard that gives you an
overview of all the key metrics
for your app.  It shows you the
number of active users across
from monthly, weekly, daily.  It
shows you the revenue that you
get from in-app purchases.  It
shows you where your users are
coming from across different
marketing channels.  It shows
them how often they are coming
back to your app.  It shows you
how -- how much time users are
spending in your app, the in-app
purchase activities they are
making and that this
distribution of your app
versions across different
devices.  But here is the cool
part.  We also layer on top
unique Google insights that give
you the breakdown of the
countries of where the abuser
base is and also demographics
and their interests -- the user
base -- you get all this from
the two lines of code that I
have just shown you.  Now if you
want to drill in and get deeper
insights, you can log analytic
events to get fine grain events
that are happening inside your
app to get a deep understanding
of how users are behaving.  For
example, in the case of the
bingo game, you can highlight or
measure things like how often
users highlighted an app.  Or
how often they have made a
mistake.  You can drill in and
see these events happening as
they -- for different
users.  Another key concept is
audiences T let's you group your
users based on their behavior
and user attributes.  Here we
have predefined your userbais
and specific audience for those
who have made in-app purchase.
Let me show you how to create a
new audience.  I just click new
audience and now just type in a
name.
So how many of my users are
Canadian purchases?  So I can go
into properties and there it
is.  And, they have taken an
event in-app purchase.  Boom,
there you have it.  Now I
created an audience and whenever
I have Canadian users making
in-app purchases, they will be
ground in this audience.  The
two key things to know about
audiences, first it lets you
drill in to filter your
dashboards and data to get
deeper insights.  Here is the
overview of my entire app.
Let's say I want to zoom in on
just the purchasers.  The graph
looks very different now.  Now I
can really drill in to see how
my paying users are behaving and
another aspect of audiences is
that it is integrated across
other Firebase features so you
can take targeted actions.  For
example, being able to send
targeted Notifications on
experiments to specific Groups
which we'll show you in a little
bit.
So I talked about ways that you
can see how users are behaving
in their app.  Let's switch to
the attribution tab N this view,
it lets you see where your
users are coming from.  Not only
just where users are coming
from, but we also provide the
next level of insights on what
actions they are taking and you
can go back and attribute the
actions to the source that they
came from.  For example, in the
case of in-app purchase, you can
set up your different marketing
channels that you may be
advertising across different ad
networks and see which of those
Drive the most in-app purchase.
So that way you can tell not
only which channel drives the
highest volume of users but
which of those drives the most
valuable users.
Another insight that Analytics
use is the concept of funnels.
So going back to the bingo game,
you can see how many users are
able to make it through the
tutorial, as an example.  We
also have another view, the
notion of cohorts or user
retention that shows you how
often users are coming back.  So
after the first time users
launched my app on Day 2, Day 3,
how often are they coming back?
And we also show you a cohort
view for week after week.  There
is a lot to go through
Analytics and what I have just
shown you was just the overview.
We will have a second session
after this here in the same room
to talk more about specifics on
Analytics and share the best
practices with you.  So if
you're interested, be sure to
stay around.
Let's switch back to the Slides.
>> JAMES: We just seen a
fantastic overview of just how
powerful Firebase Analytics is.
Now let's jump into the
products to help you develop
your app.  We'll start with our
backend services and first
authentication.  So most apps
want to know who a user is so
they can provide them a more
personalized experience and this
is exactly what Firebase
authentication does.  It helps
you with identity and user
management.  We support e-mail
and password log in, social log
in through Facebook, Twitter,
GitHub and Google.  And another
-- and we also integrate with
the your existing system if you
want extra flexibility.  There
are two core things to note
today.  First, is authentication
now runs on the same technology
that powers Google's own
authentication systems.  And
second, we have a brand new
out-of-the-box UI library.  It
helps you implement your log in
flows using best practices and
stops you from having to
reinvent the wheel so you can
get up and running quickly and
it's open source and on GitHub.
Authentication integrates with
other Firebase features T will
let you grant users access to
the realtime database on a
per-user basis.  Speaking of
which, let's move over to the
realtime database.
It's probably a feature if you
used Firebase before, you're
most familiar with.  It's a
cloud-hosted, no-sequel, Jason
database.  Whenever you write
data into the database, it
stores and sinkinize itself out
to multiple clients to every
client who cares, in
milliseconds.  Now this realtime
functionality is perfect for
building rich, collaborative
applications.  And your users
are used to these and we let you
deliver.  Nowhere should people
see the phrase, pull to
refresh, ever again.
Next the realtime database also
has a core function where it
stores data in memory or on disk
on the device.  And this means
when you're going through a
tunnel or you lose Internet
connectivity, your app stays
responsive.  When you come back
online, everything synchronizes
back up to state.
The next feature I want to talk
about is Firebase Hosting.  So
if you're building a web or
mobile web application, you
should use Firebase hosting to
hosted your HTML, CSX, Java
script and images.  It's backed
by a CDN for global low latency
and we give you an SSL
certificate so it is secure by
default.  We are announcing the
price of bringing your own
custom domain to Firebase
hosting is now completely free.
[ Applause ]
So you might want to store more
types of data that just
structured on your database or
static assets for Hosting.  One
of our biggest features is the
ability to store files, like
user profile pictures, videos
and audio files and we heard
you.  So today, we are
announcing Firebase Storage.
It's easy file Storage.  It
handles poor Internet connect
activity and backed by an
accessible from Google Cloud
Storage.  So that means you get
the full power of GCS like
global cashing and it's
accessible using the global
cloud storm APIs so you could
integrate it if you had existing
infrastructure.  Let's switch
to the demo and we'll see this
in action.
So, what I'm going to do here is
request audience participation.
So I have an app built 5A
Storage into it.  And I'm going
ask you all to throw up your
hands and make some noise while
you're at it.  So now we'll go
to the 5A storm console, refresh
this tab, and we'll bring up
the latest picture.  We'll open
up in my browser.  And there you
all are.
[ Applause ]
Pretty cool, right?  So the next
feature I want to talk about is
Firebase Remote Config.  So
Remote Config gives you key
value pairs inside the Firebase
console and when you update
them, they push down to your
application without you having
to publish a new version to the
store.  You can use this for
pretty cool things like putting
dates behind your features and
rolling them up slowly to user
base.  You can use it to
optimize your checkout flow or
onboarding flow.  Or you can
target different types of
behaviors at different users.
So, let's take a look.  Using
the Bingo Blast as an example, I
have instrumented here the
number of seconds you get to
complete each bingo level.  And
we saw earlier Francis had
Canadian purchases and it turns
out we know from Firebase
Analytics that people who pay
for our app in Canada are just
way too good at bingo and we
want to make it more difficult
for them.  So what we are going
to do is go over to conditions.
You can see I have got
conditions so I can target
things with my iOS and Android
users or random 10% of my user
base and I'm going to create a
brand new condition.
I'm going to call it Canadian
purchasers.  And here you can
see the different types of
conditions I can target so
things like device language,
device country app version.  So
I want to say user audience to
connect with Firebase audiences
in Analytics and I'm going to
choose the iOS version that
Francis is working on.  And I
have Canadian purchases.  I
create a condition.  Boom.  I go
back over to my parameters and
select level 3 and I'm going to
Selectica nade an purchases and
instead of giving them 40
seconds, we'll give them 50.  I
publish changes and now everyone
who is a paying user in Canada,
my bingo game is now harder for
them.  So that is Remote
Config.
We'll go back to the deck.  So
we seen how Firebase can help
you with your backend services.
Now let's take a look at how we
can help you ship a higher
quality application.  We are
doing this in two ways.  The
first of which you were
introduced to last year at
Google I/O as cloud Test Lab.
Now we are bringing it into
Firebase and rebranding as
Firebase Test Lab for Android.
Test Lab lets you test on the
most popular devices before you
push your app to production.  It
gives you reports and screen
shots and it will let you run a
custom set of instrumentitation
50's we'll give you robo tests
by default.  You're not going to
catch everything in the lab.
So that is why we have built
Firebase Crash reporting so you
can get Crashes come in from the
field.  We'll prioritize by the
Crashes frequency and impact.
We'll let you drill down the
version of your application and
the OS and also integrate it
with Firebase Analytics.  So
we'll go back to the demo and
show you these.
So I'm going to start with Test
Lab.  The first thing I need to
do is click run a test.  Here, I
have the option to import
instrumentation tests if I have
already written them but I
haven't.  So I'm going to click,
run a robo test and I'm going
to up load an APK.  So we are
going to wait just a few seconds
for this to up load.  And we'll
try that one more time.
And the demo Gods are against
us.  So after I have up loaded
this, what it will let me do is
pick the devices I want to run
on and the Android OS versions.
Once I have done that, it will
spit out a set of results and I
can go into them here.  So here
is one I made earlier.  So we
can see all the devices.  So I'm
running this on motoX galaxy
S6.  By clicking into one, I get
these
four tabs along the top.  One
of the most interesting ones is
activity map.  So this is going
to give me a holistic view of
how Test Lab is seeing my app on
this screen, on this device,
and how it is spiderring through
it.
So I can get things like screen
shots to double check that it's
appearing okay on this device
and I can get a video of Test
Lab walking through the
application.  I can see logs and
filter by errors, warnings, and
info.  So that is Test Lab.
Jumping over to Crash reporting,
let's look at some actual data
from Bingo Blast.  So I can see
in the last 30 days on this top
card, I have seen 9,300
individual Crashes.  They have
been clustered into 119 types of
Crashes and they have affected
in purple, 2,600 users.  In this
second card, they have been
prioritized for me.  So I can
say that this has affected 1,200
users and has occurred 5,300
times.  I can click into this to
get details.  In this top card
I will get aggregated details
about the type of iOS version it
is affecting and the devices it
is affecting.  And then I can
go down here and cycle through
each instance and view the
stats.
So now we'll go back to the deck
.  So that was Test Lab and
Crash reporting.  And they help
you ship higher quality
applications.  Finally, I want
to talk about some of the
integrations that we have done
with Firebase and other Google
services.  First, we have
integrated Firebase with Google
Play.  Things like in-app
purchases flow directly through
Firebase Analytics and
application not responding or
ANRs flow through to Firebase
Crash reporting.  Secondly,
Google Cloud.  We have connected
Firebase with Google Cloud.  So
you can easily attach Google
Cloud resources to your Firebase
application easily.  So this
let's us do things like access
Google Cloud Storage from
Firebase and from Google Cloud.
And you can expect much more of
this in the future.  We are
working closely with the Google
Cloud functions team to help you
bring light weight computers to
Firebase.  That's how Firebase
can help you develop an
application.  I'll turn it to
France toys talk about how to
grow a business with Firebase.
>> FRANCIS: So James just talked
about how to use Firebase to
develop an app more easily and
tools to help you build a higher
quality app.  Now I'm going to
talk about how you can use some
of the Firebase features to grow
a business.  We are going to
talk over ways that you can use
Firebase to acquire more users
and engage more users and also
to earn more easily.  Let's
start with user acquisitions.
Now we know that users often
discover apps through
word-of-mouth.  And I'm sure
many of you have got an e-mail
from a friend that shared an app
with you.  But oftentimes when
you click on that link, you end
up in a static page like this.
It doesn't even know what type
of phone you're on.  And
developers built this because
the work actually to turn a web
link into the specific state in
your native app is a lot of
work, especially when you have
to do this across two different
platforms.  So let's assume the
user is able to go in and choose
the right download and able to
download your app and starts it.
Now, she would come into this
generic screen.  Not really the
bingo game she was invited to.
And that isn't a great
experience either.  So
all-in-all, this is really high
friction not only for users to
share but also for you to
promote your app through other
web channels like using E-mail,
SMS or posting on a tweet.
Imagine wouldn't it be nice if
there was a much easier way to
share a link, that link could be
dynamic and figure out the type
of phone that user is on
whether or not the app is
installed, and if not take them
to the right store and when the
user installs it and starts it
for the first time, it will take
them to the right content of
the app but not only that, it
will take them to the specific
state that the link was meant
for them.  The user was invited
to bingo game challenge and now
they are brought right into it
with these three clicks.  To
help you solve that problem,
Firebase Dynamic Links is what
does that for you.
Dynamic Links provide single URL
to configure users on the fly.
That one URL also works across
different platforms and the
states can be preserved even
through software and we provide
analytic Sites as well as.
Let's switch to the demo and
show you how dynamic set up
works.  Here I'm back to
Firebase console on the left.  I
can access my Dynamic Links.
And top right I can create a new
link.  It's really simple.  So
let's say I have a fall promo.
I can type in the URL right
here.
And now I can select a
specific app I want to send them
to.  So I have a production app
and a test app.  I can select
the right app and likewise, on
iOS, now there are other
advanced options as well but to
get the basic link created it's
that simple.  Just create now a
short link that is automatically
generated for you and you can
use that link and the right
behavior will happen just as I
had shown you earlier.
Here are some other examples of
links that I have created and
now you can go in and see how
many clicks these individuals
clinks have driven through.  So
use that one link and use it
across different campaigns or
choose to create different links
and be able to see which of
these links are performing best.
Let's switch back over to the
Slides.  So on the topic of
sharing with Dynamic Links,
another great way to help you do
that is with Firebase Invites.
Firebase Invites provide a drop
in widget to help you create a
sharing for users through SMS
and e-mail.  But not only that,
Google will also suggest choose
to sender, the recipients they
should send to.  And all of this
is built on Dynamic Links so
the same behavior happens T
works across platforms when the
user clicks on the link, the
states will be preserved.
Here is an example of what
dynamic -- Firebase Invites look
like.  Over on the left, is
your app where let's say you're
running a promotional campaign
where the sender and receiver
gets 15% off.  So the sender
clicks end and now the middle
screen is the Firebase Invites
widget.  Cust nice to match the
look and feel of your app and
notice the recipients.  It's not
just an alphabetically sorted
list.  It's a list on who is
most likely to be interested in
this app.  And on the right is
the recipient who is using a
different device again because
this is built on Dynamic Links,
it works across platform and
when you click on it, it will
take them to the right spot in
the app.
So I just talked about two ways
you can Drive organic growth
with Dynamic Links and invites.
Now to feel your growth engine,
a great way to do that is
tapping into the reach of Google
through AdWords.  Since last
year, we introduced a new
feature called Universal App
Campaigns.  It's a easy way for
you to Drive installs through
the reach of Google across the
different properties.  For
example, Google Search, Google
Play, YouTube or the display
network.  You can reach over a
billion users.  All you have to
do is set a specific budget and
Google will automatically figure
out the best channel to help
you find the most valuable
users.  And we have seen
incredible traction over the
last year.  To date, we have
driven over two billion app
installs from our ads.
We have offered this on Android
and now we are expanding this to
iOS as well.  And here is the
cool part.  AdWords is
integrated with Firebase.  So
what that means is, you can take
your audiences from your
Firebase Analytics and use that
for remarketing and AdWords.  So
I can go back and send a
specific promo to my Canadian
purchasers through AdWords.
Another aspect of this
integration it lets you impouter
your events from Analytics into
AdWords as a way to track
conversions.  Not only does it
help you measure results, but it
is also helps to inform AdWords
to help optimize your campaign
for those actions.  So let's say
if this action I want is not
just a Drive install but I want
users to come in and make in-app
purchase.  I can send those
events to AdWords and AdWords
will automatically optimize for
that.
So this is a really cool way to
fuel your growth.  So I just
walked over some features to
talk about acquiring users.
Let's switch gears to talk about
how you can re-engage users to
extend the lifetime value of
these users.  One of these cool
ways of doing that is with App
Indexing.  App Indexing is a
great way to get your app
content exposed through Google
Search.  Now some of you may
have heard of App Indexing
before.  This is the same App
Indexing and now it is
integrated into Firebase to make
your integration even easier.
You can use the same SD.  And
now get your app -- SDK --
indexed through Google Search.
One thing to note is through App
Indexing, Google Search uses
that as one of the signals for
its ranking.  When you index
your app, it's a little bit way
to further increase your
exposure through Google Search.
Another great way to Drive
re-engagement is through
Notifications
Notifications.  Maniful you are
familiar with Google Cloud
messaging.  It's the most
popular messaging service that
is used by over one million
apps.  And since over the past
year, we have worked really hard
to improve the developer
experience.  We have also
expanded it across platforms so
not only is it targeting for
Android developers and also
works on iOS, Chrome and web
push W also integrated that with
Firebase as well.  Do those
three principals sound familiar
to you?  To reflect our
commitment to continue to make
this better, we are now calling
this Firebase Cloud Messaging.
Additionally, we are also
building a new feature called,
Firebase notification.  Firebase
notification is a new UI
accessible through the console
that is built on top of Cloud
Messaging.  This UI lets you
compose a notification without
writing a single line of code.
And since it is integrated and
part of Firebase, you can take
the same Analytics audience and
use that to target your
Notifications.  And since it is
also connected with Analytics,
you can also measure the
conversion events.  Let's switch
over to the demo and I'll show
what you this looks like.  So
here on the left I can access
notification view.  Creating a
notification is really simple.
Click new message.  So let's say
5 dollar promo.  Now, I can
even schedule that to be sent at
a later time.
It's a long weekend in Canada
next week.  I will send that
promo at that time, and I select
my app and now watch this.  I
can specify the specific
audience that I want to target
to my Canadian purchasers.  But
there is more.  I don't want to
send notification to get them to
open the app.  What I really
want is to make sure that they
are taking actions inside the
app they wanted to take.  For
example, if I want them to
continue on and make more in-app
purchases.  I can set that as
conversion event and the if I
want to, I can specify other
advance options like passing in
my own custom key value pair to
specify a state when they open
the notification.  So I click
schedule, confirm and here now I
have the schedule.  It's going
to go out on may 23rd.  Let's
switch to the Slides.  We are
going to travel in time to the
future.  May 23rd Notifications
will go out to thousands of my
users and now on the bottom
right there, you can see the
conversion funnel, the number of
Notifications that were sent,
the number that were opened and
the number that converted.  The
number of users who have taken
to in-app purchase action I
wanted them to.  So in addition
to using fire basis to help you
grow your audience, you can also
use it to help you monetize
more easily.  One of the most
popular ways of monetizing a
mobile app is through display
adds and AdMob helps you do
that.  AdMob helps you engage
formats from video, or native
that can match the look and feel
of your app.  To date, there
are over one million developers
that are using AdMob.  AdMob is
also integrated with Firebase.
That means you can use the same
SDK to use AdMob with your app
but not only that, you can also
use AdMob with other Firebase
products, such as Remote Config,
so you can now used that to
say, run experiments to figure
out which formats is best or you
can try to experiment with the
different positions of your app,
or if you want to supplement
your income in the case of Bingo
Blast, I can now show ads only
tow those users that are not
making in-app purchases.  So we
just talked about ways on how to
use Firebase to help you
develop, grow and earn.  Let's
switch over to hear from some of
the partners who we have been
working with and share their
experience about Firebase.
>> JAMES: We want to show you
two videos.  First, is from NPR.
So national public radio.  A
well renowned broadcaster here
in the U.S. and then moving
towards a broadcast model and
trying to understand how they
can best engage their mobile
users and the second is called
IS.  A high-tech start up based
in New York City developed an
innovation location-based
application.  Let's take a look
at what they have done with
Firebase.
[ Music Playing ]
>> We are remanaging what a
listening experience could be
outside of the radio.
>> It's the radio but better.
It has all of the great stuff
that we have spent 40 years
perfecting.
>> We see the opportunity of
reaching a more diverse audience
that have a device in their
pocket at all times.
>> My name is Mike and I'm the
lead mobile developer for NPR
digital media.  The.
>> Nye maim is Nick and I'm the
innovation accountant.
>> I'm senior Product Manager
for NPR1.
>> Some of the biggest
challenges in any mobile app are
that first impression when the
user first installs the app you
have a limited amount of time to
convince them to keep the app
and to get engaged in the
experience.
>> Trying to figure out how to
get users into the content as
quickly as possible was the real
focus of integrating Firebase
and Dynamic Links.  Using
Dynamic Links we were able to
shorten the number of
interactions it takes for a user
installing the app to get from
the promoted content to the
content, from 20 to 3.  So, that
use ser able to get into the
content.
>> We are I driving more and
more listening per user every
week.  It's astounding.
Creating play list of content
that are configured by the
podcastero a station or by us
internally and with Firebase we
have that at our hands.
>> Having the Analytics product
interact with things like
Dynamic Links, Remote
Configation, Cloud Messaging, it
adds a real multiplier affect.
>> And the integration with the
broader Firebase suite, I don't
have to go outside the platform
to figure out what is working.
So it's not just about shipping
the product faster.  It's about
analyzing the results faster.
And the integration with all the
other Firebase products, we are
excited about all the things we
can learn from it.
[ Music Playing ]
[ Applause ]
>> So we will go quickly into
the next video, which is IZ.
>> We started IZ on the living
room couch and we start today
because of the problem we had
which was asking the same
questions of our closest
friends, where are you and what
are you doing?  We were baffled
by the fact that there wasn't a
solution that solved this
problem and we felt like we
could build one that was better.
>> The value that IZ drives for
all users is knowing which of
your friends are nearby.  So if
you look around where we are
right now, an a reason a how
many times have people gone to a
basketball game, hockey game or
concert and found out the next
day they had friends at the same
event?  Think about those
moments that are missed because
they didn't know they had
friends there.  So what we are
solving is letting people know
who is nearby and making those
moments matter.
>> My name is diesel and rhyme
the founder and CEO of IZ.
>> I'm Co-Founder of IZ.
>> Weis felt no reason
users -- no reason for text
messaging should be different
from this and Firebase let us
solve that.  Firebase allowed us
to have a unique user
experience and cut down on
developing time.
>> The most valuable asset you
have is your team and time.  And
what Firebase allowed us to do
is save 50% in terms of time by
moving that much quicker with
the product.  It is a game
changer.
>> We are using eight features
from Firebase right now.  They
are Analytics, Remote Config,
Dynamic Links, realtime databais
and more.  Traditional they
would be eight different places
and now we go to one place with
the Firebase console.
>> We are eager to launch this
product in a big way.  We are
seeing how people are using the
product and how they are
inviting more are and more
friends that were concerned.  We
are growing very, very quickly.
So, we sleep a lot easier at
night knowing that we got
Firebase.
That is there to build that
infrastructure.
>> If you're a developer, use
it.  We love it.  And it has
enabled us to focus on
developing the user experience
and not worry about the things
in the background that shouldn't
be there.
>> We are super excited to be
part of Google I/O today and
making available everybody here
at the event, has access to IZ.
So, invite your friends and see
what is going on at the event.
In addition for everybody that
is of waking at home, they can
also sign up for the app at IZ
app.com /I/O.
[ Applause ]
>> Jim's James it's fantastic to
see these two great -- JAMES:
Using Firebase and NP thromgive
their mobile users a better
experience and understand what
is going on in their application
and IZ, the other end of the
life cycle just getting started
and using the full power of the
Firebase platform to build and
grow their application.  IZ we
chose because you today will be
wandering around shoreline.  You
should download it and you can
see where your friends are
throughout the arena.
>> France France recap, we
just walked you through the
product suites of Firebase --
FRANCIS: -- they can help you
quickly build an app easily
without managing your own
backend infrastructure.  We also
provide a set of tools that
help you build higher quality
apps.  We help you acquire more
users and reach them and will
also earn more easily and tie it
all together to give insights
and help you develop, grow and
earn.  Now remember when I
started this, I showed you
getting started with Firebase
only required copiy and pasting
two lines of code.  You can do
this right after this by going
to Firebase.google.com and if
you want to learn more about
each one of the features we just
talked about, we have specific
sessions on each one of these
features.  So be sure to look at
the schedule since we just
unveiled Firebase today, the
schedule has just been
published.  Be sure to check
them out.  If you have questions
along the way in looking to
integrate Firebase, you can come
to one of our office hours at
3:00 today or at 6:00 with many
members from the Firebase team
here and our goal is to help you
integrate Firebase before you
leave Google I/O.  Thank you
very much for coming out.
>> JAMES: We are also here in
the yellow T-shirts.  So you
have the office hours but also
grab the Firebase team and we
are giving this to you early so
we are early in our life cycle
and we want your feedback.  So
please provide it to us and help
us to work to make the platform
even better.  Thank you for
coming out.
[ Applause ]
May 18, Use Analytics
to Build Extraordinary Apps,  3
p.m.
Ladies and gentlemen, you're
staying for the next session,
please find your seats.  If you
are not staying for the next
session, please exit the tent
and find your next session.  We
would love you to stay but you
need to find a seat.
>> All right!
How is everybody doing?  Are we
still piling into the room, it
looks like?  Nice!
All right, so I'm Russ Ketchum.
I lead product management for
Google Analytics for apps and
now for Firebase Analytics.  So
I'm going to be on stage in a
few minutes by some of my team,
by Steve and Fontaine, and
before we get to that, I want to
take a minute and have
everybody think about
experiences that they had with
apps on an every day basis.  So,
we have all had those magical
experiences where you download
an app and almost from the
minute you do, you open it up
and you're in love.  It
immediately starts adding value
to your life.  The user
experience is beautiful.  You
may even go on to make it a
permanent fixture on your home
screen and before long, you
can't imagine your life without
it.  So, for me, Uber is an app
like that.  So I am based in
Southern California.  Here I am
in the Bay Area.  I don't have a
car or rental car or worrying
about cabs.  Uber.  When I'm at
home, WAYZ an app like that for
me.  There is another experience
we had with apps, the ones when
you install them, you almost
immediately regret doing T the
user experience suction if you
can ever see the user experience
because the app keeps Crashing
and then it has Notifications
you never asked for that serve
no purpose and without fail,
right when you're more
frustrated than you can be, it
has the audacity to prompt you
for review.  So as developers,
none of us want that app to be
our app.  Especially when we
know how extraordinary apps can
be.  But of course, you all know
this better than anyone else.
Because typically your app is
your business and every
interaction with your users
matters.  Now as developers,
there is something else that you
know about apps.  And that is
that building an app is really,
really hard.  I mean, think
about it.  There is so much
going on, so much you have to
get right, and you build the app
but how are you going to make
it successful and how do you
measure success and understand
the things that make an app
successful and not?
So, a big challenge there is
that apps are generating just a
mind-boggling amount of data.
So people take their phones out
of their pockets and check them
more than 150 times a day.  I'm
standing on stage at I-O and I
have already pulled my phone out
twice.  And that level of
interaction just generates a
mind-boggling amount of data.
And very few tools are even
capable of capturing that amount
of data, especially if you're
not one of the big developers.
Let's assume for a minute that
you could collect all that data.
How would you go about
detecting the underlying factors
that are driving your success
and failure?  What causes your
revenue to increase one day and
fall another day?  What users
are most valuable to you and
where are they coming from?
What are the experiences in the
app that they are throughly
enjoying?  You need a set of
powerful analysis tools that
work fast and are easy to use.
And you also need to be able to
very quickly put that data to
work for you.  It's not good
enough to simply look at your
reporting.  You need to put that
data into action.  And so,
without having to deal with all
of the complications of bundling
and multiple
SDKs that make your app bloated
and results in a Frankenstein
monster
with all these pieces never
designed to work together.
Fortunately this is something
that Google can help with.
Let's talk about the new
Firebase.
We just heard a lot about it if
you heard pieces of the Keynote
or in the session before this,
but we want to look at it from
the perspective of Analytics.
What we used Firebase for
internally at Google was a
unifying force to bring all of
our app developer efforts
together.  And the result is now
this single suite of tightly
integrated products all designed
to help users or help
developers rather, build their
apps, grow their engagement or
user base, and ultimately to
earn more money.  And while we
talk about these as stages or
steps like in a journey, I think
a better way to look at them is
like this.  So you can manage
thin as a virtuous cycle where
each step is feeding back on
itself and reinforcing the
learnings from one stage to
benefit the other, all to build
a better app.
And so that is exactly what we
are doing with Firebase.  We are
making it easy for you to tap
in to that virtuous cycle and
succeed with your app.  So we
heard Francis and James a few
minutes ago talk about how
Firebase is this tightly-
integrate set of tools.  We have
other session that is go into
all the different features
throughout the week and over at
the Firebase sand box.  But at
the core of Firebase, is
Firebase Analytics.  And now
this is an entirely new offering
focused specifically on the
needs of mobile apps but it
benefits from our decade-long
experience running Google
Analytics, which is the most
popular Analytics service in the
world.  So we think given these
learnings, that Firebase
Analytics is going to be really
exciting for developers and here
is why.
So first, Firebase Analytics is
completely free and completely
unlimited.  Even for --
[ Applause ]
Completely free and completely
unlimited!
[ Applause ]
Exactly!
This is true even for largest of
apps.  So now all developers
can understand all of their data
and without compromise.  It is
free.  There aren't hit limits.
There is not sampling.  There
is no quotas.  There is no
nothing.  Free and unlimited.
Next, it works automatically
right out-of-the-box.  So what
this means is when a developer
gets started with Firebase and
they add it to their app, for
any reason, even the most basic
implementation, they are already
set up with Firebase analytics
and it's already measuring
things for them automatically.
Now the automated measurement
features are just the starting
point and Steve will come up
here in just a minute and show
us how easy it is to take that
further.  Firebase Analytics is
also seamlessly integrated
within Firebase and across many
other Google products.
And this is going to provide you
as a developer with a single
source of truth as you take
action across all of Google and
Fontaine will come up here in a
minute to to show us what that
looks like.  The thing I really,
really want to stress is that
Firebase Analytics is cross
platform.  It works just as well
and is just as easy to use on
iOS as it is on Android.
And so with that, let's go ahead
and get our hands dirty and
write some code.  Actually I'm
not going to get my hands dirty.
Steve is going to get his
hands dirty and I will hand it
over and he will show you how
easy it is to use Firebase
Analytics as you're building
graph.  Steve?
>>
[ Applause ]
>> STEVE: Thank you. Thank you
very much.  I'm Steve Ganem and
I'm a Project Manager on
Firebase Analytics and I'm going
to walk you through a real
example of how to use Firebase
Analytics as you develop your
app and there will be a little
bit of live coding there as
well.  And but just before we do
that, I'm going to take a step
back and see how you get started
with Firebase in your app.
We get started with Firebase
very easy as 1, 2, 3.  You take
your app, you add the SDK to it
and add a config file and you're
up and running.  More
specifically, you register your
app on the Firebase console, you
download the SDK for your
target platform and then
download a configgation file
that has your unique app ID in
it and drop those into your
project and build.  All that
remains at that point is to
initialize the SDK which is code
list on Android and two lines
of code on iOS.  And this is a
one-time set up to do for any
and all Firebase features and so
the beauty is, regardless of
what feature attracted you to
Firebase in the first place, if
you come this far, you're
already live with Analytics in
your app.
Now, what does it mean to be
live with Analytics?  Well,
Firebase Analytics works
out-of-the-box.  So just by
initializing the SDK over a
dozen events are captured
automatically for you.  These
are events are critical related
to in-app purchases, user
engagement, your push
notification campaigns and more.
This is all done for you.
Now, of course you still need
the ability to log custom events
and there is an API for you to
do that.  But what if you aren't
sure what you should be
logging?  Maybe you're new to
Analytics or want to make sure
you're practicing using best
practices with Firebase
Analytics?  That's what our API
documentation and our help
center can help you get started.
In our help center, you'll
find documentation on a list of
suggested events for various
types of apps so that you can
map your experience and your
features to these events and log
them.  There is examples and
suggestioned events for things
like retall apps, travel apps
and of course games.  So, what
is it like to log one of the
events and how much work is
that?  That's what I'm going to
show you in just a minute.  And
we'll do so in the context of a
real app.
Transworld endless skater is an
app that is live right now in
the App Store and on Google
Play.  It is a skateboarding
take on the endless runner genre
where the player's goal is to
land as many tricks and combos
as possible to keep their run
going as long as possible and
the developer's goal to to keep
the lights on as long as
possible and they do that by
monetizing with in-app purchases
driven by a virtual economy
which is a very common pattern
in video games.
And so thinking back to the list
of suggested events I showed
you on a previous slide, these
spend virtual currency event
will be important because we
want to measure the Trends and
popularity of our various
virtual goods.  So let's take a
look at what it is like to log
that event.
Switch to the demo, please.  So
here we are in X code.  A
function that is called when an
item is purposed from the shop.
So first thing I'm going to do
is get Analytics instance and
call log it in with name API.
And I'm going to log the spend
virtual currency event.  So just
having done that, I'm flagging
every time a user actually
purchases something.  But that's
good and that has some value to
it.  We want to add context
with parameters that help us
understand what is being
purchased and what the price
was.
So not only does Firebase
suggest program -- events for
you to log, but it also
prescribes certain parameters
for events to help you get the
most out of your reporting.  For
this spend virtual currency
event we see item name, virtual
currency name and will value,
are prescribed.  So we'll add
those as well to the event.
And there it is.  With one line
of code, we are now tracking our
virtual currency spend in the
app.  And now you can log up to
500 distinct events in your app
and unlimited volume as Russ
mentioned.  And even though I
only logged three parameters,
you supply up to 25 different
parameters so you get a sense of
the detect to which you can
measure your application.  But,
what if you didn't have time to
do that?  What if you only he 10
minutes and you asked your
develop tore check out this
Firebase Analytics things?  How
much value would you get from
logging one event?  Let's follow
this through a bit.  We made
this change to the code.  We
make a new build.  You are 65
send it to test flight.  You --
you archive it -- they tell you
everything is looking good.
Submit it to Apple and breeze
through because you know what
you're doing and then you
release it to the public
.
And now let's see what the
reporting looks like.  So here I
am in the skater project in
Firebase.  The changes we made
are the iOS version so I select
that here.  This takes me to the
Analytics dash board.  This is
a beautiful list of Schwartz
graph that is have all sorts of
value -- charts and graphs.  And
everything on here is actually
captured for you just by
innickizing the SDK.  This whole
dashboard lights up when it is
inserted into the app and
initialized.  So let's go
through each one of these cards
so you can understand what is
here in depth.  First of all,
I'm looking at the last 30 days
here.  So all of the date that
I'm seeing is daily from the
last 30 days and compared
against the previous 30 day
period.  So dotted lines
represent the previous 30 days
as well as the percentage
changes here.  This first card
is the active user's report
breaks down monthly, weekly and
daily active users compared to
the previous period.  The one to
the right is average revenue.
So it breaks it down on average
revenue per user and per paying
user.  The revenue in Firebase
Analytics is the sum of your
in-app purchase revenue captured
automatically and your
eCommerce revenue.
Next we see first open
attribution.
This say report on the influx of
new users from various
campaigns that you're running.
So you get a sense of which
campaigns are effective in
driving use tours your app but
also looking at the lifetime
value column here, which ones
are most effective at driving
valuable users so you can double
down on those.
Over here on the left is the
retention cohorts chart.  This
helps you understand that for
given set of users that started
using your app around the same
time, what was their pattern and
regularity of comingba tock
your app.  How well did you
retain them?  This here, user
engagement is particularly
important for mobile apps.  User
engagement is the amount of
time your app spends in focus on
the foreground or device.  That
is what we care about as
developers.  How much mind share
do I have.  How many eyeballs
do I own?  So you see that value
plotted over 30 days.  As you
actioner acquire more users or
improving making optimizations
on your reason tegs, you should
see this moving up to the right
-- retention.  The next metric
is daily engagement per user.
Take that daily engagement
metric and divide by the number
of users so you measure the
impact of your engagement
optimizations.  So if you're
trying to make your app more
engaging, have users spend more
time in it, you come here to
verify the changes you're making
have the impact you expected.
Or if you have a utility app
meant to get users in and out
very quickly, you will see your
daily user engagement go down.
So we see the in-app purchases
card which is pretty self
exexplanatoriy and shows you
which are popular.  And then
these app version card right
here.
This is particularly important
because in our scenario, we just
launched a new version of the
app.  We want to measure how
quickly that is being adopted by
users.  It could be it has 100%
adoption and that's great but
some users stick around to the
old version.  That's important
to know because you just made
changes to your scalp your game
player experience and if a lot
of users aren't adopting the new
version that data won't reflect
that.  Next we have the device
model and OS version, pretty
self explanatory.  If you
optimized for phone and you have
a lot of tablet users, you can
verify assumptions and making
sure you're putting in the
effort necessary to deliver the
best experience to your users.
The last three are locations,
demographic and interests.
These are -- I mentioned before
that all of this is populated
automatically by initializing
the SDK.  And all of these three
cards they tell you more about
who is using your app.  Not so
much about what is going on in
the app but it is incredibly
insightful on what is more.
This is Google's data being
injected into your reporting and
adding value to your reporting.
I find that interesting, this
tells you more about what other
things your users are into.  And
these insights are great
because as you're producing more
content in your app or running
campaigns to try to attract more
users like that, now you have
an insight into what else they
are into.
So I have covered a lot here and
there a lot of detail.  You
don't need to memorize it all.
If you memorize one thing,
remember that there is this
question mark up here in the
upper right corner if you click
on that, on any report
throughout Firebase Analytics,
it brings up in-product help.
So here on the dashboard there
are
two videos that can give you
background on Firebase Analytics
and there is also information
about the reports and the
controls including links to our
help center which is rich with
information about the product.
So the dashboard as insightful
as it is, as automatic as it is,
it doesn't tell you much about
how users are using specific
features within your app, which
is what we are out to measure
here.  To do that, you need to
log events.  So let's head over
to the events tab.
The events tab list every event
that was logged by the SDK, both
automatic and the ones you
logged manually.  For every one
a report will be generated to
dig into it more deeply.  In-app
puncheses is one logged
automatically.  This is what you
can expect from automatic
events.  You'll see a report
over the last 30 days of the
event count so that is the
frequency the event occurred.
Number of users who purposed
in-app purchases and the count
per user and the value.
Now value in the context of
in-app purchase is pretty
obvious.  That is revenue.  I
want to spend a minute on this
because it is one of the most
valuable but subtle features of
Analytics.  Value is a context
sensitive parameter.  The so as
I mentioned in the context of
in-app purchases it is revenue.
But if you have a travel app
and you log a flight event, it
could be that your value is
distance.  So that the
accumulative value is the total
distance traveled by your users.
Or perhaps you have a music
streaming app and you have an
event that is listened to track
and then value could be
listening time so that the
accumulative value is the total
amount of time listened to in
your app.  So whatever makes
sense for your events, I really
encourage you to use that value
to track those things.
We also show event locations,
demographics and event per
session for every event report
as well.  So you get a since of
who is logging those events.
Finally we'll get around to
looking at our spend virtual
currency report, the one we log
with one line of code.  Now
you're getting a since of all
the value to get by initializing
the SDK and logging.  In
addition to the standard metrics
we saw around event and user
count, you'll see a report on
virtual goods.  This is what we
are after and just by logging
that one events, we get this
table rich with date at about
what items are the most popular
and how many times that you were
purchased and it is broken down
by currency type.  This uses
two types of currency, CRD which
are earned and bucks which are
purchased.  It's important to
understand what is being
purchased and what is being
purchased with each type of
currency in order to fully
understand our economy.
So you can apply either bucks or
CRED as a filter to your report
to the get a sense of what they
are purchasings and now we are
getting somewhere because now we
see what content is popular,
that gives us a sense as we
continue to develop and
toiterate what new content we
should be making, maybe we
should be exposing or promoting
some of the conthat he went is
less popular that we expected to
be more popular and so forth.
Also in actuality, it's not
one-size-fits-all.  Some users
graphitate towards certain types
of content and others towards
other types.  So it's important
you drill deeper to get business
insights here.  That is what
the filter up here allows to you
do.  This global filter control
is on all reports in Firebase
analytics and allows to you
drill in and I filter by
different user properties and
audiences.  User properties are
captured for you automatically
such as age, gender, device
model, app version, and more.
In addition to ones that you can
log yourself.  So if I want to
see what 18-24-year-olds are
buying in my app, I can apply
that filter.  Compare it to the
25-34-year-olds.  So, it's
really quick.  It updates fast
so you can go deep and drill and
have hypotheses and try to
discover new things about your
usage.
So, let's switch back to the
Slides now.  Now as valuable as
all of this reporting is, some
of you might have custom needs
that can't be served by
standardized reporting and every
Firebase app can be linked to
big query which is Google's data
Analytics data warehouse in the
cloud.  So you can perform
custom analysis on it or join it
with external data or export to
the to some external endpoint
of yours to do what you need
with it.  So that flexibility
and power is there for you as
well.
So, I feel like we barely
scratched the surface.  We
looked at two of the 7 tabs but
Fontaine is here to tell you
more about how you can grow your
app using Firebase Analytics.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> FONTAINE: Thank you, Steve.
So, while it is critical your
core app experience as a
developer, once you have a
strong foundation, it's worse
thinking about -- it's worth
thinking about driving
engagement with the users.  And
that is why we built Firebase
Analytics to be a growth engine
for your app.  Whether you you
consider yourself a developer or
a marketer.
So we are creating opportunities
for you to boost engagement and
grow usage with your apps.
Let's pick up a France world
endless skater where Steve left
off and for the purpose of this
presentation, you can go ahead
and think of Steve as the
developer and me as the
marketer.
And while it is perfectly
reasonable for Steve as a
developer to focus on growth for
his app, Firebase Analytics
also works well for
organizations where there is a
little bit more delineation
between roles.
So, Steve talked to us about how
developers can measure events.
But there is one type of event
that he conveniently didn't
mention.  And those are
conversion events.  Or just
conversions.
Think of conversions as the key
business drivers that you're
really trying to optimize your
business around.  Optimize your
app around.  So, first opens.
You can think of these like
installs.  Or in-app purchases.
These are obviously conversions
so we'll automatically enable
those for you.
But, different businesses have
different types of conversions.
And so you can come into
Firebase Analytics and mark any
of your custom events to be
conversions in our UI.  You can
do this without writing any new
code just by coming over into
the events tab and on the far
right column a section that says
enable conversion and you
can toggle it on for any event.
Now, marking an event as a
conversion, this unlocks a
couple of features for that
particular event.  For example,
attribution.  So you can start
to understand which of your
channels are driving the most of
those events for your
conversions.
So, Steve instrumented spend
virtual currency a couple of
minutes ago.  I know that is a
business driver so I'm going to
go ahead and market a conversion
in the UI.
And when I mark it as a
conversion, it gets added to the
attribution section
of Firebase Analytics.
This is another tab that Steve
didn't get to cover.
Attribution is really what I
consider to be the home base for
the marketers that are going to
be using Firebase Analytics.
Now, on Friday, we are going to
be diving a lot deeper into the
atbution tab to understand how
you can do cross channel
attribution.  So I'm not going
to go too deep on it now.  The
one thing I want to highlight is
our lifetime value reporting.
So our lifetime value reporting
or LTV reporting this is the
type of thing we are trying to
optimized for with convergence.
So I want to highlight this and
it is available on our
dashboard and available here in
the attribution section.  So,
let's talk about how we can
actually Drive conversions.
Rather than focus on how we can
do that with Google's ad
products which we can do, I want
to talk about how to re-engage
our existing users by pairing
Firebase Analytics with
Notifications.
So Firebase Analytics and
Notifications.  Notifications
are really powerful way of
bringing your users back into
the app to Drive a particular
type of engagement.  This is
certainly true with transworld
endless skater.
Firebase makes it incredibly
easy to send Notifications on
both Android and iOS.  And like
Firebase Analytics, it is
completely free and unlimited.
And while Steve didn't show this
earlier, it only took him a
couple of lines of code and a
couple of minutes to actually
instrument Firebase
Notifications in his app.  And
just like that, we are ready to
send Notifications.  But let's
pause for a minute and think
about what that actually means
in this context.  With Firebase
we make it really easy for you
to engage in a conversation
directly with your users.
That's really powerful.  But,
insert obligatoriy comic book
reference here, with great power
comes great responsibility.
So, we all know examples of apps
who have really just gone off
the rails when it comes to push
Notifications.
Maybe they are sending them way
too frequently and it starts to
feel spammy or I can think of
countless apps that just send a
one-size-fits-all notification
that really doesn't apply to me
personally.  So when you're a
developer, and you're using
Notifications, it's important
that you strike the right
balance between relevance and
frequency.  And this is exactly
what you can do with Firebase
Analytics and Notifications
together.  Let's look at how to
do that in the context of
transworld endless skater.  So
first, we are going to want to
use those audiences that Steve
highlighted to actually craft a
group of our users.  So we can
define certain criteria and
we'll be walking through this on
a demo in a minute.  The second
is then going over to
Notifications where we can craft
the content of the message,
figure out who we are targeting
and what the copy will be and
how often we are going to be
sending the message.
And then together, this allows
you to tailor your messages
towards each of those Groups.
So, back to transworld endless
skater.  Steve had instrumented
that spend virtual currency
event earlier.  And the great
thing about it accident we are
not just capturing the fact that
the event happened, we are
capturing metadata as well so
I can see what spending
their virtual currency on.  It
is important because I want to
send a push notification to
users who would actually be
inclined or interested in the
content of this message and
specifically, I'm interested in
adding a new level.  One of the
things that you can spend your
virtual occurrenceo in the game
transworld endless skater is to
unlock new levels.  So when I'm
sending my push notification, I
want to make sure it's targeted
at the right group.  My new
level will be called rooftops
and I'll be sending a
notification to a very specific
set of users to actually cover
this.  So, I'm going to go ahead
and dive in at this point.
Here we are on the event
section.  Now I'm going to move
over to the
audiences section.  So now here
I'm on the audience section.
You can think of audiences like
the way to slice and dice users
to get certain segments of users
you want to focus on or
analyze.  There is a couple of
different ways to use audiences.
One is to do reporting.  So, I
can see here a list of all the
audience that is I have been
creating over the last few weeks
and if I wanted to do reporting
and understand how they are
behaving, I can click on them to
see a report.  So here I'm
going to click on males 25-34.
And I can immediately see a
report on them.  How many users
are in that report, what is
their demographics?  Here I can
see
their interests like Steve
highlighted earlier.  So this
particular segment of user is
interested in online video and
online games, which is
reasonable considering this
particular filter I added.  And
another way to use audiences is
to actually just apply it as a
filter.  Steve highlighted this
earlier but can be used across
the Firebase Analytics product.
And then the final way that I
want to highlight that you can
use audiences for is for highly
contextural targeting
information.  You can target
users across other Firebase
products but you can also target
users across other Google
products.  So we are really
trying to bring all of these
products together with a single
language in fair base
audiences.  So, coming back, I
said I wanted to add a new level
and sent push notification to
the users to encourage them to
spend their virtual occurrence
tow unlock this level.  So, I
need to be thoughtful about who
my audience is going to be.  So,
if I think back, what is a
reasonable behavior that might
in Kate that users could be
interested in unlocking levels
in the future?  This isn't a
trick question.  It is pretty
obvious under our nose.  If
users spent to unlock levels in
the past, it is probably pretty
reasonable they would be willing
to do that again.  So that is
going to be my target audience
that I'm going to create right
now.  So if I come over into new
audience, pops up audience
builder where I can construct
the conditions of my audience.
Now my audience name, I'm going
to say users who purchase level
and then my audience
descriptions all say spent
virtual currency on a level.
Now, I'm actually going to
select the specific criteria for
this.  Coming into the
selector, I can select either an
event or user property.  You
seen a bunch of user properties
earlier and for my event we
agreed I'm going to select spend
virtual currency.  And then, I
don't want to just target
anybody who is ever spent
virtual currency.  I really want
to hone it down on that
specific set of users that spent
virtual currency to unlock a
level.  And this is again where
those parameters come in right?
Steve had added those three
extra calls, those three extra
parameters in the actual event
logging and when I add a
parameter, you can see here are
those three parameter names we
saw Steve instrument earlier.
I'm going select item name and
my operator, I'm going to leave
as, contains.  And I'll go ahead
and say level.  So I'm saying
narrowing it down to anyone who
has spent on an item name that
contains level.
So at this intpo, I can hit
create.  I created this audience
earlier.  So I'm going to go
ahead and use the audience I
created earlier this week.  So,
purchased level two.  I'm
highlighting it right now.  This
is the audience I'm targeting.
So creating my audience that
was the first stage.  The next
stage is actually going into
create the notification.  So,
coming into Notifications,
create a new message, and let's
see, get ready for some fun.
Unlock level 3 now.
Message label, I'll call it
rooftops, since rooftops is the
name of this level.  And then in
terms of a delivery date, I'm
launching this level tomorrow
evening so I'm going to send
this push notification Friday.
So I'm scheduling it.  I can go
ahead and select Friday the 20th
and noon seems like a
reasonable time.  It might be
their lunch hour and will be
willing to play games and I want
to leave it on recipient time
zones.  Now I get to the
targeting.  I want this to be on
my iOS app and I'll add one
more criteria.  Here I'm
selecting audience.  I can see
this list of audiences that we
just saw over in Analytics
because they are the same.  So,
of all these audiences, let's
see, purchase level two at the
bottom here.  I can see this
particular audience has between
1-10,000 users.  That seems
right.  And I can go ahead and
add that target.  Great.  A
couple other things.  Let's see,
conversion events.  We talked
about this
earlier.  This particular wing
set allowing me to construct a
funnel in the different stages
of notification process.  So the
first part is the whether or
not the Notifications were sent
and how many were opened and
then I get to define what that
final action is that the
conversion should be.  So, we
have already been talking about
this but of course it will be
spend virtual currency since
that is the specific action I'm
trying to Drive.
Excuse me then, I don't have any
advanced options -- and then --
save this as a draft and let's
see, all right, I'm going to go
ahead and schedule a message.
So I can see here it's going to
get sent on Friday.  It's
targeting that user segment.  So
scheduling.  Great.  So,
message goes out.  How do I know
if anyone actually got the
message?  Well, Analytics
naturally can help here as well.
So if I come back into my
event section, see all my
events, I can see here a couple
of events, notification open.
Those are among the automatic
events that Steve highlighted
earlier.  I'm going to click
into notification open.  So this
is where I can see exactly how
many users actually opened my
Notifications.  You can see I
sent a notification last week.
You can see the spike here as
well as the residual opens that
happened after that.  So now I'm
looking at this
particular event.  What is
interesting is over here, I can
see the relative campaign
side-by-side one another.  So if
I want to click on rooftops
upsell, the message I sent, it
immediately applies this chip at
the top and now all of my
dashboard is being narrowed in
and filtered down to this
specific group of users.  So
it's cool to be able to say all
right, let me see for this
particular event, for this
particular notification, how
effective was it at driving
engagement in my app?  So, so
far I have been talking a lot
about notification analytics and
how they can be used together.
A lot of cool places you can go
where that.  This is really
just the beginning.  But I'm
going to step back for a minute
and talk about a couple other
ways you can use the other
Firebase growth tools for your
app.  So, let's move back to the
deck.  Sky scanner, a leading
global travel
search business with over 50
million monthly users, put
Firebase in their app.  And
within their app, you can do
things like book travel, compare
prices for things like flights
or hotels or car rentals.  And
they decided to use Firebase
Invites to augment their growth
strategy.  They did this again
in a couple of different steps.
The first was naturally
identifying their most valuable
users with Firebase audiences.
For them, that was the users who
actually made a booking through
the app before.
The second step was realizing
that those users were their
target group to actually target
the Firebase Invites with.  And
then finally, they used Firebase
Invites to allow those users to
share the app with their
frequently contacted folks using
SMS or e-mail.
So they did this in a couple of
different ways.  First of all,
they asked their users to rate
the app and if the user rate
today highly, they gave them the
opportunity to share the app
via Firebase Invites.  The
recipients of these invites
didn't just receive a link to
the app, but when they actually
went on to download it and then
later open it, they arrived at a
specific screen in the app.
They were Deeplinked in after
install.  So it was really able
to close the loop with the full
invitation experience.
And so, users could seamlessly
share the app with their friends
and their most frequently
contacted peers.  And within
just two weeks, sky scanner saw
hundreds of personalized
invites.  And we already see
them getting results.  They are
seeing strong adoption of the
app from the users who are
coming from this channel
specifically.  So, enough about
growth.  I'm going to hand it
back to Russ to talk about how
to actually make money with
Firebase.
[ Applause ]
>> RUSS: Thank you Fontaine.
And Thank you, Steve for showing
us so much of what you can do
with Firebase and Firebase
Analytics.  So I know I speak
for the three of us when I say
one of the things that was the
most fun about building Firebase
was with collaborating with so
many expert teams across Google,
all focused on the needs of app
developers.  But when it comes
to making money with apps, at
Google, the team that you talk
to is AdMob.  So AdMob is
synonymous with in-app
advertising and for good reason.
Because in-app ads are the
Number 1 montization mechanism
for apps.  AdMob has over a
million apps monetizing with
AdMob today.  It's pretty
impressive.
But if you spend time with the
AdMob team and if you talk to
experienced publishers, what you
learn is that one-size-fits-all
monnization is a thing of the
past.  Different types of users
monetize differently which means
the more you understand about
users and users behavior, the
smarter you can be about making
money with your app.  And by
linking your Firebase app to
AdMob, you're paving the way to
using both products together to
maximize your earning potential.
So we are going to return to
scape for just one more minute
and what we seen is that Steve
showed us that skate monetizing
using in-app puncheses but a lot
of industry data that says that
only between one-5% of users
actually ever make an in-app
purchase.
That means that 95% of these
users are going unmonetized.  If
this holds true for skated,
that could mean there is a
massive opportunity just waiting
for them.
Fortunately, since skate uses
Firebase Analytics, we don't
have to rely on a rule of thumb.
We can just look's data.  And
so here I'm back on the Firebase
Analytics dashboard and I
highlighted the monthly active
users and what I can do is
basically apply a filter here.
So, Steve showed that in-app
purchase is one of those events
that is logged automatically on
both iOS and Android.  Fontaine
showed how easy it is to use
events to build an audience but
since purposers are so important
to so many developers --
purchasers -- Firebase creates a
purchaser's audience for you.
When I apply that as a filter,
sure enough, the number of
purchasers actually goes way
down.  And that means that there
is a massive opportunity to
money ties.  So Firebase can
help us introduce a targeted
monnization experience using
Remote Config and tap that
opportunity space.  Particularly
when you bring Firebase
Analytics and Firebase Remote
Config together.  Just a quick
example.  So, we saw that skate
uses in-app purchases and now we
can use a Remote Config to
control and set aside users to
make sure that purchasers never
see ads.  Next, Steve was called
to developer earlier and I'll
stick with it.  Steve could ad
mob to the add by using Google
Mobile Ads SDK.  And he built an
add placement, say a banner.
If he wanted to, he could log
another custom event, maybe add
clicks and this then wire up
that add experience to be
controlled with a Remote Config.
So coming back, he has already
set it up so his spenders will
never see ads, now Steve just
needs to wire up the other
configgation.  Target the group
of users that aren't his
purchasers and now they are
experiencing ads.  And if that
feels a little aggressive, maybe
you don't want to turn ads on
all at once, control that by
adding a percentage.  Just like
that, we have multiple targeted
monat thization experiences
happening at the same time in
skate.  We hope you're excited.
So Firebase Analytics is a
really, really exciting thing
for us.  We think it will be
very powerful for developers.  I
know we have covered a ton of
ground and we are just about out
of time so we want to live you
with a couple of points in
summary.
Firebase analyt 6 free and
unlimited on iOS and Android.
It works out of the bock with
automatic measurement.  It
seamlessly integrated across
Google.  All to help you
develop, grow and earn.  So, a
couple of housekeeping items.
We have got the sand box, office
hours, we have another Firebase
Analytics session that Fontaine
mentioned on growth scheduled
for Friday.  And if you're
looking for specific next steps,
we would love for you to sign
up for Firebase right now and
start using Firebase Analytics.
There is a lot of great help
center content and we are ready
to help you in the sandboxes.
On behalf of Steve and Fontaine,
thank you for coming out and
enjoy the rest of I/O!
[ Applause ]
use er
user.  The system basically
listens to people and it can to
the app developer, it
can listen to the use er on what
to do.  The problem with find
right is if we allow both the
use er and the X developer to
say,
go into multi-window imposed,
the experience becomes confusing
use er doesn't know what
multi-window mode is.  So for
now, we are going with entry
mode to window mode is an use
er-
user-initiate ed action.  Most
of
the feedback we've been getting
so far is that, yes, this is a
user initiate ed action.  You
put
it into that, they don't know
what it is, they're going to get
confused.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, so my question
is more like a testing side.  So
have the top activity that's
live and the bottom one, but say
is going to respond correctly,
you go to the unpause ed one but
doesn't have the concept anymore
because it's wrapped around your
main activity when you put the
other activity into multi-user
mode as well.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: Okay. So
if I understand your use case
correctly, you have two
activity
activities running in the same
process and you're testing the
one above and your test is
written in such a way where it
needs to continuously get focus,
one below.
>> Yes.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: So I guess
my question first is how is
focus switched?
>> Say you're simulate ing
the
use er, they tap that one to
make
sure it's working, then you want
to the other and make
sure your app is working, but if
actual test will die.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: I don't see
would your test die?
>> Because it uses the
activity complex saying, oh,
longer using the app.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: What
testing are you using?
>>
Because if you swap --
>> WALE OGUNWALE: I'm not
sure what's going on.  We do
have office hours after this.
It's either something where the
testing infrastructure, or I'd
like to understand how your test
structure ed a little better.
I guess --
>>
I'm just worried.  I
haven't tested.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: I would say
go test it but I've tested tons
of it and I know it works.  But
if you do find something, please
filing that to us.  We have you
covered.
>> Thanks.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: M-hmm.
>> I got here a little late
but I don't know if you address
two instances
of the same activity, one in
each of the two screens, so I
could have two YouTube apps
running at the same time and
watch two videos, for example.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: So I think
you have two questions in there.
not misunderstanding, is if
if you
can initiate multi-window mode
with two activity ies without
initiate ing that, yes, that was
covered earlier and the answer
is no.  Mainly for use er
experience, we don't want the
use er to be in a mode that they
It's something we're starting in
the ecosystem and as we start it
and the ecosystem becomes
mature
mature, we'll see how it will go
go, but right now the app and
multi-window mode is conflicting
Your second question is can
you have the same activity
instance in both windows.
Answered that one earlier, the
yes.  You can have
multi-window activity ies,
instead one being in the
background
you just have both of them
visible at the same time as long
your app is appropriate in
that mode.
>> Thank you.
>> What if we have a window
such as the  right here?
>> WALE OGUNWALE: I'm sorry.
>> What if we have an
external monitor for secondary
read?
>> WALE OGUNWALE: External
monitor?  So, currently the
support
we have for secondary
displays, right, is not
changing
changing.  One example would be
presentation mode.  Right?  You
can still only have one activity
your
presentation is in secondary
activity, on the second window
display you're only going to see
Which makes sense, it's the same
way if you're on your desktop
and presenting
presenting some apps you
don't want everybody seeing your
screen casting, which is
everybody see my desktop, you
see everything, right?  On top
of that, we've not added any
additional functionality.  We
just make sure we did not break
existing ones.
>> Hey, how's it going? Good
Good.
>> I have questions.
>> WALE OGUNWALE: You have
Like for office hour
hour?  Yeah, we have office hou
r
hour.  By the way, me and my
team are going to be at the
today at 5:00 and
tomorrow at 11 and Friday at 11,
any additional questions you
might have.  Yeah. especially
around Emojis and.  (laughter)
If there are no
additional questions, I guess we
can wrap it up.  Thank you for
coming and enjoy the rest of I/O
(Presentation ended at 6:32
6:32 p.m. CST)
This text is being provided in a
realtime format. Communication
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) is provided in order to
facilitate communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.
********
Android Battery and Memory
Optimizations
May 18, 2016
7:00 p.m. CST
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1 877 825 5234
+001 719 481 9835
www.captionfirst.com
********
This text is being provided in a
Access Realtime Translation
(CART) is provided in order to
facilitate communication
accessibility and may not be a
totally verbatim record of the
proceedings.
********
>> Can you guys hear me fine?
Oh, the lights are bright.  All
right.  Welcome, and thank you
for coming.
And, first of all,
I want to thank every one of you
really hot.  So thank you for
that.  My name is Ashish Sharma
and I'm the tech lead of the
Volta team inside Android, and
we focus on making the battery
life of Android devices great.
And I'm joined with my colleague
Meg.
Meghan., everyone
everyone.  My name is Meghan
Desai and I'm a team leader.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Today we're
going to talk about two issues
on a device that when running
significantly impact the
way use ers use their phone,
battery and memory.  We're going
to take away the pain from
diagnose ing battery problems
because we know it's a national
problem.  Extended battery life
is one of the top requested
features on mobile devices
today
today.  The phones in our
pocket
pockets are more powerful and
more capable than any time .
And there are hundreds and
thousands of applications that
keep us informed and entertained
it's a phone who's doesn't die
the a the
end of the day.  Now how many
here in the audience are worry
ied
that their phones will not last
the end of the day?  All
right.  Almost everyone.
And to speak for the same
fact, we've seen that there are
not more of battery
apps that claim to help extend
battery mobile devices some with
as 100 million downloads
or more, so it's clearly a that
our use ers care
about and we here at the Volta
team at Android are very
passionate about making it
possible.
So let's look at, where
does the power in our mobile
phones go.  It turns out when a
screen is on it dominates the
power consumption on your phone
more than anything else.  When
you have your screen on playing
a game or watching a video or
maybe searching the internet and
the screen turns out to be a
very expense ive component on
the
device with much more power than
But our phones also spend a lot
of times in our pocket when our
screen is off, like right now, I
hope it's. when is screen is off
and the use er is not actively
engage ed in using the device,
the
power consumption now starts
getting taken by the CPU and the
network radios.  So there might
be a background job or sync
trying to access the internet to
data in the background
costs power.  So when it comes
to optimize ing for power when
the
screen is off, we want you to
think about three main design
principles.
Reduce, defer, and coalesce
any and all background activity
that you can.  Now, what do I
mean by this?  Reducing the
background activity for an app
when the use er is not actively
engage ed or is not actively
using device is something that
only application developers,
that only you can do.  You know
the logic of your applications
you know the constraint
that you're operating in, and
you also know what your use ers
want from the application.  But
it's really, really important
that we try to stay away from
that urge, from that temptation
to push data on to our devices
and keep them fresh even when
the use er is not actively using
thought battery life was
important and our use ers are
just
like us so we really want you to
background activity that's
possible that you can help.
For activity that you
cannot completely eliminate and
there's gown be some cases like
that, we want you to really
about deferring it  time the
device is on
charge er because the moment the
device is plugged in, any
activity you do essentially
becomes free and the use er does
not incur any battery cost for
it.  And finally, we realize and
be cases where you cannot get
rid of them completely, can you
not defer them until the device
gets on the charge ers, so for
those we want you to start using
the job schedule er API because
that is an API that lets Android
background activity not just
from your applications but from
other application as well in
order to make the most of the CP
traffic.
Now, this is really
important.  I want to spend a
minute here.  Every time your
device wakes up from suspend or
it activates the mobile radio to
it for a very small amount of  a
fixed cost that
needs to get incurred.  Your
device goes into this high power
and there's going to be a
fixed overhead every time you
wake up the device.  So there's
an access cost.  The more
applications can batch together
any of their background activity
efficient the system becomes and
power on the device can be
really, really reduced.
Now, there are some feature
features in the platform, in the
Android operating system that
automatically help you do a lot
defer and coalesce in
your applications.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: That's right
Ashish.  Let's start by
reviewing a couple of the
feature questions launched with
Dose and standby.  Let's say you
and you
wake up in the morning and your
phone is dead.  You're going to
have a bad day.  But what doze
tries to do is use a lost that
activity that Ashish was talking
the morning, and these
activity
activities are on, it's not your
battery.  So let's
take a look at how doze works.
Let's say at some point, you put
stationary.  It's sitting on
your entitle stand.  It's not
battery, not plugged it and the
screen is off.  The way we tell
is we use a
significant motion detector, so
that's required for Doze.
At some point, we realize
the device has been still for
some time.  At that point, we do
sure the device is not in a
steadily moving vehicle.  So we
use a GPS earth.  At that point,
use L network
access, and there are no more
WiFi scans an their jobs or sync
syncs and alarms get deferred
until the next maintenance
window.  So maintenance window
is where all that background
activity gets coalescet to.
This is where all the activity
is put for a brief time.  So
what we're really trying to do
is balance battery life with the
expectation of content freshness
that use ers have on their
devices
devices.  Now the device
continues to be stationary on
battery ies with the screen off,
then we see this repeated
pattern where the Doze windows
growing exponentially.  So
that's D
oze in the Marshmellow
release.  To optimize that, we
used app standby.  Apps that are
get considered to be on app
standby.  So some kind of tit or
notification on the lock screen
that you've seniority
application is specifically
launched by the use er.  If this
network access and it's jobs are
deferred to when you plug in the
device.  But once you plug in
the device, if the application
is still not used, then it will
still be considered standby and
the next time you unplug the
device, it's jobs will again be
on stand be.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Hang on, so
instant message ing app and I
don't receive a message for a
long time then it goes on app
standby then I might miss the
video calls.  Because it's on
standby?
>> MEGHAN DESAI: No, for that
your messages are going to get
So for that use case,
we launched          launched
Google message ing
which now is Firebase message
ing
if you saw the message today.
active to the message and put up
whatever notification it needs
to to the ice er whether it's
instant message ing or whatever
it's called.  Normally, it gets
batched to the maintenance
window so for device that's
don't have Google Play services,
this is where Cloud message ing
lives, for devices that don't
have Google Play services, we
actually shift Doze and App
Standby, to work with our eco
ecosystems to identify an
alternate Cloud-based push
message ing service.  So we
don't
have them enabled unless they
have Googling play services or
some alternate push-based
services.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: So that
takes care of my message ing,
but
what about the other use case?
I often listen to my music on my
home.  Does that mean when the
device goes in Doze my music
stops playing?
>> MEGHAN DESAI: No, no. We
got you covered there as well.
We're going to make sure your
keeps playing.  For that
case, we actually disable Doze
and App Standby.  This is a
service that has to have a
persistent notification and such
a service will be exempt from
App Standby.  Even
though -- I also said that
alarm
alarms get deferred.  There are
some use cases where alarms are
important, part of what the
application needs to do for a
use er so for those we launched
new APIs that will trigger in a
limiting way for Doze.  And
finally for use cases that
cannot be accomplished by Doze
and App Standby, we have a white
applications
applications to that will cause
the applications to be exempt
from Doze.  This is only for
specific, narrow use cases that
you can read about on our device
before your application gets
published. of
this makes a lot of sense, Doze
when my device
is not being used or when I'm
using my application.  How did
we do?  Do we have any numbers?
>> MEGHAN DESAI: I think we
do have numbers.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Great last
year when we announced
Marshmellow, we saw that Doze
App Standby can increase the
life to almost double  also saw
30 percent
increase based on Google
applications that we have, so
clearly Doze and App Standby are
principles seem to work.  But
I'm still thinking about one
thing.  These cases make sense
when I'm not using my device but
around with my device like I am
today and am actively using all
of our devices on the
devices on my phone?
>> MEGHAN DESAI: That's
right
right, Ashish.  Most of the time
our phones are not stationary.
We have them in our hands or
pockets and are moving about the
We wanted to bring the
battery system of Doze to the
average user as well and that's
why we're extending Doze in the
Android region.  Let's think
about how that's going to work.
Again, think about these bars as
activity, at somebody point you
turn the screen off and it's not
that, this time on the order of
minutes, shortly after that, the
And now this is a lighter, gent
gentle er doze than what you saw
with Marshmallow, only going to
restrict some and any other job
will get referred to the next
window.  And Doze
repeated cycle will ensue after
that so long as the screen
continues to be off and again,
the idea is that we're balance
ing
battery life with freshness of
content.  In the maintenance
windows, these restrictions are
lifted to allow any activity
window to continue.
So let's quickly review the
Doze that we talked
about in
Marshmellow.  Let's take a look
what happens, as you would
screen is off but the
amount of time hasn't pacessed
yet for Doze to trigger.  At
this point, the extended or
lighter version of Doze will
kick in and you'll see that same
maintenance window and at some
point, the device will realize,
okay, the device has been
stationary for the amount of
time required for Doze to kick
in and at that point just like
it does in Marshmallow, the full
set of Doze restrictions will
kick in.  Their alarms will get
deferred and there will be no
more GPS or WiFi scans because
the device has been stationary.
So we're very excited about
will a of  -- all of you is if
you've already enabled your
applications for Doze and
battery life, you don't need to
do much more.  Fore ground
services continue to be exempt
from Doze and App Standby so we
make sure that Ashish's music
keeps playing., so we've been
talking
a lot about background services
an their impact on battery life.
little bit and talk about
background services and their
impact on memory.  So, let's say
you're trying to do something on
your phone and it's just really
slow and sluggish.  So you're
trying to take a picture of the
camera and you just miss that
moment because your phone was to
e too slow.  And you know what
I'm talking about.  Background
services have an impact when the
screen is on as well.  That's
what we're going to focus on
next.  At any given time,
there's lots of stuff happening
in the background services.
When a device enters a low-
low-memory situation or if it
just happens to be a low
low-memory
device, what happens is there's
not enough memory to run all
that stuff in the background
while you're trying to use that
device at the top.  At that
point, Android is too busy
trying to swap in and out of
memory to let them do what they
need do in the background which
apply ies pressure on what
you're
trying to do and the net result
is that you get this frustrating
Background work is pretty
important.  Let's figure out why
sent out on the device whenever
something happens and the
implicit gets sent out to
anything that's happening versus
sent out to a certain type of
application.  What makes this
particularly bad is there a
often these broadcasts are
listened to.  The refers for
these are declare ed in a
specific
way in the application file.
What that means is that the
application doesn't actually
have to be running for it to
receive this broad cast and get
it.  This would cause
applications that are not even
running to be woken up, brought
into memory, and while tried e
Android
is doing that, the application
that you're actually trying to
use is slow.
A quick example of this is
a broadcast called connectivity
change.  This is a broadcast
that gets sent quite frequently
on your device, any time you
switch from WiFi to cell or any
time your internet activity
changes, this gets sent out.  In
the
receive ers in a manifest file.
perform in the background and
you get a frustrating experience
This is the problem we're
trying to solve.  What do we do?
.  It's not  because
background
activity is actually pretty
important.  So what we're
envisioning here is that hangs
perform any background activity
using explicitly jobs and sort
of reduce their reliance on
background server eers and
statically declare implicit
broadcast.  Applications static
refers would no longer get woken
up.  One-time declare ed refers
would continue to work.
Explicit broadcast refers would
continue to work statically or
at one time but the statically
declare ed implicit broadcast
refers would be the ones affect
affected.  Secondly, we assume
that it's no longer necessary
for background services
services.  Fore
ground services will still
continue to work, so Ashish,
your music will still continue
to work.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Well, thank
you for that.  All this sounds
pretty scary.  These are pretty
big changes.  Are they coming N?
Do we need to change
recall of our apps for N which
is coming soon? not or N but you
United to
-- you need to change your apps
soon.  Today we're just giving
you a preview of what's coming.
going and we're planning to
launch these when we think
they're going to be ready in
some future release and we'll
target the apps in that release.
In the N-release we want to give
you the tools to start testing
your applications and giving
this feedback as you think about
changing your applications to
use job schedule er where you c
an.
We're also remove ing a few
broad
broadcasts that we think are
particularly harmful in the
system today and I'll talk about
have some commands you can view,
and start reviewing the
applications, how your
applications behave under these
conditions and send us the
feedback.  Let's us know what
implicit broadcast that you're
currently dependent on, what
kind of background services you
have that you can't move over.
Okay, Ashish, I think your
specific question was what's
actually going to be changing in
little bit about that.
First, I already talked
about connectivity change as
particularly harmful
harmful
broadcast, so we're getting rid
of that one.  This means if you
have declare ed a refer
receive er for
this broadcast, that will no
longer work.  If you've
declare ed
run time, that will continue to
work.  For other applications,
we want you to use job schedule
er
scheduler, and job schedule er
already has network semantics.
The other two are new picture
and new video.
These are two more implicit
broadcasts that are sent right
when the use er takes a picture
and they're sent by the camming
raw and that's sort of the worst
en you want a lot of
stuff to be happening because
you want to be focusing on
taking the picture.  So starting
just those targeting N, all
applications.  These broadcasts
are pretty important because
they unleash some pretty cool
uses.  One is unload
-- uploading a photo.
Maybe that can wait.  We're
actually triggering on content
provider changes.  The media has
a content, that could be the
trigger there to upload that
photo.  The cool thing about
that is now because you're using
optimize when that should take
place.  Doesn't have to happen
immediately when you're taking
the picture, it can find the
optimum time to do it.  S I've
been talking about job schedule
er
scheduler, but just a show of
hands, how many of you have
actually heard of job schedule
er?,
that's a good number but I also
see a lot of hands not up so
maybe it's an important time for
to review what this really job
schedule er API is,
so let's do a quick review so
that everyone here is on the
same page.  The job schedule er
API, think of it like a wrapper
around any background activity.
So any background sync, any
background activity that you
have, job schedule er is the way
to think about schedule ing
those.
And this is slightly a paradigm
shift.  What you're doing is
letting Android know that I have
ask tasks that need to be done
and you specify certain triggers
something you try and take care
of yourself.  So let's take a
couple of examples.  These  when
you request
Android to schedule your job
could be based on a certain time
So say you have a job
that's important, not exactly
urgent, it doesn't need to
happen right away.  You can tell
time within the next one hour.
And what Android would do is
once many applications are using
the job schedule er API, it now
has this context about all the
background activity from the
different apps that needs to
happen and it's going do a good
schedule ing your job at
just the right time so that the
efficiency of the CPU and
networking radios can be
maximize ed.  Now what you can
also do is specify triggers
based on network connectivity or
a whole bunch of photos or video
videos that you might have on
your phone.  Now, it's a really
good idea for such an app to
schedule or to specify a trigger
typically has more bandwidth and
it's less expense ive in terms
of
money and it costs less power
than the radio, so that can be a
Then finally the thing which is
my favorite which comes back it
to the whole deferring the
device is on charge er, you can
specify that control, too.  You
can tell, here's a job that I
want to get done, and trigger it
when the device is charge ing.
But not just that.
Because, every time you
plug in the device may not be
the best time for all of the
background jobs to start firing
up.  Say, for example, I saw
some power outlets outside.
You've been here since this
morning.  Your phone is running
low.  And you find that power
device and you plug in your
device to get maybe five to ten
minutes of charge.  And right
then if all those apps fire up,
that's going to be a not so
pleasant experience for you
because your device will be slow
charge so what you can do is say
the device is charge ing and
should not be being used.
Android is relatively smart so
it will wait a while, make sure
it's a good time to schedule
awful those background jobs and
trigger your job right then.
So we've seen that the job
schedule er API is relating
important and it will help you
optimize, defer, and coalesce
your activity not just in
activity or battery
but also in interprets of memory
example of how the job
schedule er
works and how easy it is in a
few lines of code to get your
job done.  I'm showing you a job
object, let's create an object
using builder.  We can specify a
network type unmetered.  Now,
what that typically translates
to is a network that doesn't
cost money and most WiFi
network
networks fall into that so in a
way, for sure specifying the
WiFi activity here.  So, let's
say I want my job or my app to
sync up every 24 hours.  It
doesn't have to be by the hour,
1e
but once every day is fine for
me.  So what I'm going to do is
frequency of 24 hours and
here comes the favorite part,
you do this when the device is
on charge er.  So you specify
the
charge ing length and those four
and it's done.  Now Meghan also
talked about something very
interesting, an extension of the
job and that is to take into
account the memory conditions or
device so now job schedule er
also
does activity ies based on
content
contents on your device.  So the
example that Meghan gave was it
you're trying to take a picture
or a selfie of your kid and at
that moment you just want to
trigger another shot and if your
phone gets slow that might not
be a good time to start upload
So you can tell job
schedule er that you're wanting
this when the picture is taken
but there's a little bit more
room, it doesn't have to start
with right when the picture is
taken.  And the job schedule er
is
pretty smart, to prioritize all
the applications that is in the
fore ground or running fore
foreground services to calculate
app, that app should get
priority or all the other jobs
that might be non-critical.  And
finally, job is
based on RAM
available, so depending on the
R
RAM available, or if the memory
conditions are not ideal or if
you're running low on emergency
room, then only a few jobs or
the top priority jobs will get
schedule ed first before all the
other ones get precedence.  So
these changes are interesting.
Let's take a look at a quick
code sample of how you introduce
update.  You get a service, you
create a builder object, and you
last example where we had
specify ied constraints on the
network type, what we adhere is
a trigger content and you can
schedule your job and that's it.
You're done.  So, this is all
good.
Job schedule er was  lollip
op, we also
have on a device that is running
and that is GCS network managers
managers.  This slide doesn't
say GCS network managers.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: Yeah, that's
right.  It's actually a Firebase
job dispatcher.  So today, as of
the Firebase launch, launching
Firebase job
dispatcher.  The cool thing
about Firebase job dispatcher is
that it's an open source that
essentially is providing the
same services that job schedule
er
was but in a background
compatible way.  It's available
not only on
Android but soon on
iOS.  On Android it will use job
will use job dispatcher.  So
let's take a look at a quick
example.  This is an example of
create ing a simplification job
service that encapsule ates a
code
that whatever your job needs to
do, in the background you put in
builder from the dispatcher,
give it the service that's
around all the activity
activity.  In this case, I'm
just giving the constraint that
I want it to happen on an un
unmetered network.  That's it.
Schedule ed.
So pretty simple.  Very
easy to use to run a background
So we've been talking
a lot about different platform
features, a lot of APIs.  These
sounds like they're going to
have a huge impact but how can
we be sure?
>> ASHISH SHARMA: That's
right.  It's not an easy problem
suffered with for a while, and
how do you relating
make sure that your app is
behave ing the way that you
intend
it to be when it comes to these
battery applications or worse,
if your app is draining
more battery than you think it
should, how do you diagnose that
poll?  How many of you have
tried diagnose ing battery
problems on your applications
applications?
Okay.  Some.
Now, for the others who did
because you found it too hard to
diagnose battery problems.
Because I've been in that same
Well, you can be honest.
But, so, diagnose ing of battery
Good thing we have a tool.  And
logs on the device
that can help us do that in an
easier fashion and not have to
struggle through ology of the
pain.  Let's look at some of the
present on the device.  Now,
Android, data structure and
memory in all devices.  And this
log is called battery stats.
Now, what battery stats is,
device is on battery.  So, since
it's incrementing
incrementing and these counts go
on, they
need to stop at some point.  And
device and it's done charge ing.
So let's say you plugged in your
device, unplug it at ten in the
morning, if you take your bug
device now then it would contain
the whole ten huers of bug
report and stats on battery life
relevant so things like, how
long across all applications or
how much data was transferred
over the data network or the
WiFi network.  And what you can
see here is there's also a stat
lock time which tells you
exactly when the stats
stats were
reset.  This tells you exactly
what happened on your device
that may have cause ed the
battery
to drain faster than what you
would expect.
The other type of log that
is present on the device is
something that we call battery
history.  And what this is is an
event log of all of the state
transitions for components on
your device or for actions like
schedule ing a wake lock or an
application schedule ing a job
or
the device going into suspended,
coming out of suspend, or maybe
it's the network radio that got
turned on.  So there's a lot of
information here and this would
contain an event log of a
millisecond level granulari
ty.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: Wait,
millisecond granularity.  You're
telling me I have to look at
It's going to be hundreds
of lines?
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Well, it's
very obvious.  You can just make
out the problem.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: Oh, can I?
Can you guys?
>> ASHISH SHARMA: No, I'm
just kidding.  We have a tool
can help you make sense of
this called battery historian.
Many of you might be aware of
this.  What this would do is
take all of the logs that      t
hat I
mentioned that were present in
the bug report and help you look
at them in a very interactive UI
that would make clear what the
problem is on the device.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: That's I
like this.  I
like this a lot.  Where do I see
this?  Is this on my device and
settings somewhere?
>> ASHISH SHARMA: No, I know
you have a very cool and power
hundreds of
thousands of transitions on your
when you're trying to diagnose
battery problems with your app.
available on Git Hub ready for
you to download, and you can
look at the source code, modify
it any way you want.  What you
do is install it on your
computer.  Now you have your
development device, for the
stat
stats to be reset because you
want to have a good starting
point, you can either charge the
device up    up to 100 percent
when
the straits would get reset or
there is an AV command to
actually manually restart the
stats so you have a good
initiation point.  You can run
your experiment, which might
last a couple of minutes or
hours, and then at the end you
take a bug report.  Then you up
upload your bug report on your
computer and you have the
battery Histor I can't
think
historian tool to go
back to this.  So now that
you're clear on how the work
flee works for battery
historian
historian, I'd like you to come
with me on a slight tour of what
are the features of this tool.
Let's zoom into one of
these rows or a few of these
What you're seeing is the ine,
which is CPU running
and what this indicates is
whether your device was in
suspend or was it out of suspend
and doing things.  Similarly you
can see things like when was a
use er lock held or when the
screen was on and information
about any jobs or syncs will
also appear that.  And in this
U
UI you can zoom into every
little -- even when you see, no
matter how long and if you take
your curse or over that, it will
for example, we're at this point
in the UI, we have zoomed in and
it tells me exactly what the
current time was at this
instance and the red highlighted
portion now shows you the
battery level drop from 73 to 72
device to discharge from 73 to
72 giving you an indication of
what the average discharge rate
was at that time and you can see
of the events lining up
nicely so you can actually
figuring outs when your device
was discharge ed, what were the
events happening on the device.
Let me take you through an
example.  Say you have
modify ied app to start using
job er now, how do you figure
when your jobs are getting
schedule ed?  So in the job
schedule er row, you go on any
one
of those events and if you're in
clappings a bunch of these
little jobs that didn't last as
long but it will give you
information about how many jobs
were run in that particular
small box and for how long each
of those jobs were run, and you
can zoom in, if you like.
It's a very active and fun
tool.  I have a lot of fun with
it and diagnose ing
all the battery problems.  What
I want you to do is look at an
those in action.  So
we've been talking about the
Doze mode in Marshmallow that
was introduced and the lighter
version of Doze that was
introduced in the N-release, so
what I'm showing you here is a
bug report that I uploaded to
the battery historian tool.  The
that's not exactly Horizontal,
that's your battery life.  In
this case, I manually reset the
stats so it starts somewhere
around 50 percent.  And then
what you can see is let's zoom
into this little area.  When
your screen was on, you can see
that the frequency of your jobs
and syncs was fairly high.  All
the jobs and syncs were getting
schedule ed fairly periodically.
But then after the scene
has been turned off for a while,
that's the lighter
version of Doze kicking in so
some applications would lose
network access and you start to
see that now your jobs and your
syncs are beginning to get less
and less frequent and getting
batched together.  Further out,
after the device has had its
screen off for a while, and it
has been stationary, you see the
device entering this deeper Doze
mode which is shown in the blue
row there.  And when that
happens we know that the device
is not being touched bit user,
is not being used, and that's an
opportunity for the job
schedule
scheduler API to start running
and batching a lot of the
activity ies together.  So you
see
under the blue bars the job
schedule er is fairly infrequent
the maintenance windows.
Now, what's really
interesting is, and this slide
will help give you a perspective
uses the most power on phones.
Initially, when
the screen was on, my battery
level was discharge ing
discharge ing
really
fast, so you see this license
that's my battery going from 50
to 30 fairly quickly and after
the screen is turned off and
kicked in, that's when
you see that my battery is not
going very fast and might have
even -- then as soon as the
screen is turned back on we see
that the device exited the Doze
mode and you go back to that
steep discharge of what I'm
playing a game or watching a
video.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: That's
pretty cool.  So all that stuff
we were talking about with coale
coalescing actually works.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: That's
living proof.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: That's
pretty cool.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: So, once
you have uploaded a bug report
it will now show you all of the
that was collected
on this device.  So which jobs
were run, for how long they were
run, which applications acquire
ed
locks and for how long.  And
there's a whole bunch of
information here suchs
suchs       suchs as the
mobile activity, which
application used the most number
get a good overview in a very
quick fashion on what exactly
happened with your device.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: So hold on.
cool but I thought you said that
this was going to help me figure
out issues with my application.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Yes.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: Can I do
that with this?
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Yes, Meghan
that leads me to my very next
slide which is, you can actually
your app and the moment you do
that, this takes you to this app
of the same information just for
your app.  So you can look at
all the jobs that got fired,
whatever processes you were
running, how much WiFi data,
sense ors, all of this stuff
just
for your app.  And the very cool
thing I don't have in the slides
is once you pick your
application, if you go back and
look at the UI in timeline of
events, you will see in the job
schedule er row for the sync row
on the the jobs and syncs for
your applications will appear
and all else will disappear, so
that can relating give you --
relating give
really give you visibility into
how your application was
schedule ing these apps.  So we
found this to be very helpful
but there is one case that has
been especially painful for me,
and that is when you are
develop
developing your app or say you
made a change in your app and
suddenly your device is
discharge ing fast.  Now, I
write
perfect code.  I never make
mistakes.  But then my device is
this situation more than I'd
like to admit.
I'm sure a lot of us have
been in this situation for one
or the other time and for a that
we have is an AB comparison
mode.  What you can do is employ
two bug reports and if you have
a different case, what the tool
will do is highlight all the
differences that it sees between
two bug reports.  Say, for
example, it's compare ing file
one
versus file two and it's telling
used  than the other.
And let's say the screen was
less than 2.5 times and a whole
lot of other good stuff.  I
haven't shown you all of the
details but if you upload bug
reports, it will automatically
normalize those bug reports.  It
which can give you a very good
starting point as to what
actually changed on the device,
whether it was really my app or
some other apps that are doing
something that may have
accounted for this difference.
So, that's an interesting
mode and to wrap up, I'd like
you to look at one last feature
on this tool, which is my
personal favorite.  And this is
for the true geeks out there so
if you have a phone and if you
are able to modify your phone to
connect it to a power monitor
and say you were recording the
instantaneous current values
values
when the device was actually
running, what you can do is up
upload a bug report and record
these battery ies to the the
battery historian and it will
show you
what your instantaneous
draw was and what the device was
running, your draw was close to
800 million ampules but when the
hard
hardly anything.  You can't even
power discharge ed from your
phone
when you're actively doing
stuff
stuff.  And when you do this,
when you use the job schedule er
a lot of activity, it's not hard
to see that your phone will now
last much longer and really take
device that doesn't last as
long
long.
>> MEGHAN DESAI: That's
relating cool, Ashish.  I'd love
amp meter on what's
happening on my phone.
>> ASHISH SHARMA: Yeah, there
>> MEGHAN DESAI: So what's
next?  Well you saw how these go
the
battery and memory.  What we
want you to do is reduce, what
you can't reduce, defer when the
you
can't defer, at least help us co
use job dispatcher and job
schedule er instead of using
background apps.  Check out
battery historian, as Ashish
mentioned.  We also want you to
start remove ing
remove ing your dependence y ies
in your applications on static
statically declare ed background
receive ers as well as any
background services and send us
some feedback on when you're
unable to do that using job
schedule er or job dispatcher.
We'd love to hear from you.  We
want to get together.  With that
that, if you have any questions,
you can join us at office hours
in stage nine at 6:00 as well as
(Presentation ended
at 7:48
7:48 p.m. CST)
auto for
Everyone
May 18, 2016
8:00 p.m. CST
Services Provided By:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
1 877 825 5234
+001 719 481 9835
www.captionfirst.com
>> Hi, everybody. My name is
and I'm an engineering
manager on the Android Auto team
team.  So it's great to see so
many people here.  I hope nobody
we're going to talk about a few
things in today's session.
First I'm going to spend a few
minutes talking about where we
are today then a few of my
colleagues are going to come up
and do some demos, bullet
majority of this session is
going to be a deep five into how
to bring your applications into
Android Auto.  In 2013, we
launched Android Auto so create
services in the car.  In the two
now have 30
manufacturers, and by the end of
double this number to 200
support every car manufacturer.
I want to take a minute to
say thank you to all the
develop
developers to supported Android
Auto.  We've also recently
launched Android Auto in 19 new
ies including Brazil,
Russia, and India, which
brings
bringses us to 30 country ies
and
more on the way.  We've gotten a
use ers and I'm pleased to say
that the three most requested
features is coming soon.  The
first is okay Google.  Employed
already has a rich voice
database but being able to
command voice in the car is a
natural.  So we're bring okay
Google.  The second is Ways.
I'm very excited about this.
Ways has a big community, and
Waysers have been very vocal
about Android Auto support so
we've been working with Ways to
make that happen.  I think
they've done an awesome job and
you can actually see a demo in
the box that way.
The third is wireless.  We
think Android Auto is a great
experience but wouldn't it be
earn e even better if you could
use it without even having to
take your phone out of your
pocket?  So the good news is
we're working with manufacturers
wireless their WiFi.  So
these are
improvements.  There are many
more we're working on but we
can't ignore that there are over
a billion drivers who don't yet
have Android Auto.  We know many
in their car doc for turn by
turn navigation.  We think we
can make this safer by letting
people use Android Auto on their
coming soon, Android Auto will
give access to the same features
an interface that's designed for
driving.  Paco will be up on
stage to tell us more about it
in a few minutes.
(applause)
in our sandbox and I recommend
checking that out as well.  This
number of new use ers and that's
a
great thing for developers, too.
So we're excited about bring
Android Auto to new use ers but
what about the future?  We're
seeing fully digital instrument
clusters and cellular  but we
need a
platform and more importantly,
we need an ecosystem.  In fact,
s have
recognized this and are already
choose ing Android Auto for
their
IVI operating system, but they
have to do a lost work to adapt
it to an in-cabin experience so
we're putting
automotive support
support, it supports everything
that makes Android great like
multiuser and multitasking, and
it will be a full support
release.  In fact, in the
N-release coming   ing this year
,
we'll include many of these
features already iment we're
really excited to work with our
car manufacturers, and in our
sandbox we have a concept car
that we built showing off this
technology.  That's one I
recommend you check out,
although there's a bit of a line
right now.  But most importantly
importantly, we're working to
ensure that apps built for
Android Auto work seemlessly
lessly on
our built in info tainmenst
systems so there's a lost work
on that.  Let me introduce Paco
to show you some of the things
I've talked about.
>> PACO GALANES: Thank you,
Yes. good to see so many of you
here today.  Good that it's
air-conditioned in herement it's
pretty hot out.  I'm Paco
Galanes, and as Jeff mentioned
before, we are expanding the
auto platform to create new
experiences for existing drivers
by bringing the
experience like
are we have shown you in the car
expanding Android natively into
the car and that's the concept
car Jeff already announced.  I'm
going to give you a demo of how
this call works together and
show some of the features that
Jeff announced.  All right.
So we have Vincent here and
he is showing the desktop, this
is a tool that all developers
have available and it emulates
how the screen works once you
plug your phone in.  All right.
So once you plug in, you launch
into the home screen and that
gives you access to tasks that
you may perform to get started
started.
We have suggested destinations.
location.  Your time of day.  So
we can tell you, you may want to
start navigate ing to work
today.
the same Googling smarts that we
use throughout all the platform.
For those of you not familiar
with the platform already, let
do a quick walk through.
So the activity at the
bottom of the screen gives you
access to common applications
that you'll be using while   We
have media.  Of
course, you have access to your
dialer and your common contacts
.
That was an app.  Contacts.
Dialer.  There it is.  And, of
course, you have also access to
Navigation and Maps.  All right.
Perfect.  Let's go back to the
Home.  Notice that the whole
screen is a lot bigger than any
other application that runs on
your screen, and this is because
it's designed for driving.
You need to tap that screen
right.  Let's go
into Navigation now
.  Of course
we have integrated
Google Maps
with all the Navigation you're
familiar with, but we're also
popular Navigation
app, as you're all aware.  Let's
switch to it.  There it is.  All
right.  Vincent is going to pick
directions.  We're going to the
beach later today, so he's
getting a head start.  He has
the directions right there in
his favorites, and off he goes.
Great.
As with Googling
Maps               mol
Google Maps, the
same apply ies here.  We display
this in the interface but you
also recognize some of the Ways
specific features in the screen
reporting an incident right
there.  Great.  We've also
integrated message ing, by the
way
way.  Though it's mostly a voice
speaking of voice, of course,
we've enabled most of the common
Android Auto via voice.
All right.  Let me show you
ing actually
works in
the platform.  I'm going to text
him later.  Of course, he gets a
quick notification.  Message ing
is a notification driven
application.  In the alert, we
show you enough information to
know if you really need to take
it or not.  But it goes away and
always available through
the Home screen.  You can decide
to listen to the message when
it's safe to do so.  All right.
>> Here's the message.
Finishing my presentation
presentation at
Google I/O let me know when you
get there.
>> PACO GALANES: Now, he
could use voice to send you a
message or we always give you
a customize able message
that you can just pretap, I'm
driving, do not disturb me.
Note that this works on my
many, we
have many applications already
your favorite application is
already in the app.  If you
haven't integrated it yet, we'll
show you how to.  Thank you,
Vincent.  Let's switch to the
video below and let's see what
Victor has for us there.
All right, so that is a
testing harness for the concept
car that we have out there in
the sandbox . the Mazerati.
Come see it later if you have a
chance.  The concept car has a
screen powered by Android.  The
cluster right above the steering
of course.  And the
bigger infotainment system to
the right.
Very good.  Because
of the larger screen that we
have available here in the
infotainment screen, we can make
of Android to display more than
the same time
time.  You'll notice at the
bottom we have the climate
controlling application.  It
gets hotter today, so let's cool
application.  Right now, Maps.
It's already going to meet us
later.  And at the top, we have
a permanent screen where we can
show you all the running
applications and the running
activity ies and we can also, of
course, show you some
content
coming
from Google now or other
applications.
Let's look at some of the
clusters.  Shows you something
new
there, which is next from
Google Maps.  That area can also
big screen, please.  All right.
Now here we see how Victor
switched to the media player as
the main application.  And
notice that, I don't know if you
there.  Perfect.
Thank you.
For the Navigation, he has
access to all the media
applications that are out there.
pick one.  Great media      .
Media
applications have two screens.
We saw the first one with the
playback controls.  Those
playback controls are standard.
course
we have a second screen which is
for browse ing
browse ing content where
applications show
what's
available for these that you
pick.  We recommend that we keep
the hierarchy ies kind of
shallow
and that we true I to surface on
top -- try to surface on top
personalize ed content.
Frequents
Frequents, favorites, et cetera,
right.  Hope you can hear that.
>> This can help anyone can
at just about --
>> PACO GALANES: I thought he
he's in the park yesterday.  All
right, Victor will talk to you
later about how to integrate
app
apps      app
apps into the platform if you
haven't done so already.  Thank
you, Victor.  Let's move to the
phone here.  Great.  Let me show
you how the third Android
surface will work.  No new car
needed.  All have I to do is
bring up the Android Auto
application from the icon and
here I am in
the Android Auto
home screen adapted to my phone.
to you already.
I can also send Android
Auto to auto launch, when I turn
it on, for
instance.  From the screen I
have access to the
same destinations.  We talked
about before, is Android Auto
the same platform.  I also have
ongoing activity ies like media
and it can show me missed
messages or missed calls that I
may want to
return.
From the media car, I can
always go to the media
application, again.  I have
access to all the applications
running on my phone.  Books and
broadcasts -- podcasts
podcasts          podcasts
podcasts, several
music apps.  Let me pick one.
And when we launch the music a
pp
app, I can start playing where I
left off.  (Music Playing) many
but I also have access to the
full menu, just one swipe away.
By the way, the customize able
controllings
controlling
ize able      ize
customize
able      ize able
controls are also here.  Another
Vincent is going to show me that
he's already in Santa Cruz
waiting for
me.  It's taking him
a little long to get there today
the message.  Notice that the
applications in the phone
screen
screens are a little larger than
adapted for a
smaller screen size so I it tap
them while I'm driving.  As you
saw before, I don't have to tap
that notification to listen to
it.  It's always in my home
screen.
>> Here's the message. Hey,
I'm here now.  You can press the
voice button and say, reply.
>> PACO GALANES: Of course.
I could try to reply with voice,
but as always, the auto reply
there and I can just
tell him, hey, I'm driving right
now.  I'll catch you later.  The
last thing I wanted to show you
is how the power of voice
integration works with Android
Auto.  I don't know if this is
work in this environment.  You
guys are kind of quiet, so I'm
going to try.  Let me see.
Navigate to santa Cruz.
>> Sand santa Cruz, USA?
All
right.  You should reach your
destination by 7:30 p.m.
>> PACO GALANES: All right,
so I'm navigate ing, and of
course
the next turn is always
available from the home screen
miss a turn no matter
what I'm doing.
>> Turn right on to Bill
Grand parkway.
>> PACO GALANES: Let me stop
this for a second.  All right.
So I hope that this quick demo
gave you an idea of how the
platform works together.  Next
thing that we're going to
do is,
let's go back to the slides.
Perfect.  We're going to go into
more detail about how you
integrate your apps into the
Android Auto platform.  We're
going to talk about message ing
and we're going to talk about
media and remember that if you
already integrated your app, it
will run seamlessly on both
phone and car screens.  We use
the same interface across all
three surfaces.  If you haven't
integrated yet, stay around and
Victor is going to tell us how
to integrate with media.
>> VICTOR CHAN: Thanks, Paco
(Applause)
>> VICTOR CHAN: Hi. I'm
Victor.  I'm the software
engineering on the Android Auto
team and I'm here to talk about
media apps.  There are a couple
things I want to focus on
today.  First of all, we'll look
at how to make your media app
compatible with Android Auto
then I'll also provide tips to
help you provide a great media
experience inside the vehicle.
So, as you saw earlier in
the demo, media content can show
up in many different forms in
various Android devices.  On the
here, we have our media
fashion eight which is a --
facet which is a template for
the UI experience where the use
er
can provide feedback.  On the
other hand, media content can
appear more passively such as a
card inside our overview stream
or as a notification inside our
overview cluster.  I just want
to point out again, across all
these different surfaces,
whether a phone or car screen, a
implement the just once and when
that's done, Android will do all
the heavy lifting to ensure a
safe and pleasant experience.
All right, let's dive into
First of all, we need to
do the set-up because we want
Android Auto to be able to find
your app, so here I point to app
scripter.  And inside
the auto app descriptor, this
lets us know that your app can
provide media content for auto
devices.  Once we can find you,
you'll need to implement a
service.  In this case, the
media browse er surface.  Does
two
things, first of all of provides
a content hierarchy which is
what we use to create a content
browse er that the use er can
then
use to explore media types at
the same time, the media browse
er
should provide a content session
what we use to provide
playback in your app.  So here's
.
As you can see, we're extending
media browse er service compat
which is available in 22 and
high E and of course this will
help your app run on older
devices.
There are two that we need
to implement inside the services
services.  The first is the
browse er root of your content
tree.  This root itself is not a
media item, however we use this
root to retrieve a list of media
items which are then used to
populate the top level of our
content menu.  Also note that
root tents may be passed on to
you, this could be things like
suggestions and hints that
Android Auto wants to give to
you in terms of what content you
respect these when you're expose
exposing your content.  The
second method you need to over
invoke ed and you will be passed
a
parent ID and we expect you to
return a list of its children.
Let's take a look at this
on load children method.  First
of all, I want to say, if you
returning media items, try
to do so from a cache and the
reason is, you can imagine a
user is driving down the
highway
highway.  They're looking for
some songs and they're going and
list and now suddenly your app
needs to go to a network to
download these different songs
and if the cell service isn't
gracious the use er is looking
at
screen and their eyes are not on
the road so not only is this a
bad experience, it's also not
safe.  So we really recommend
you to cache your media items so
called, you're able to return
the items immediately from
memory.
Now, if you have to, set up
back through the results object.
So while we're on the subject of
content hierarchy ies, let's
take
a look at some of the common
mistakes that people
tend to make.  So in this
example here, we have a media
app that can play radio and a
separates it down into local
radio and further breaks it down
into different genres like jazz
or pop or other types of music.
In this case, the use er
has
to click at least three times
before the use er can get to the
nesting is actually not very
good because you can imagine
again, the user is on the road
and tapping the screen at least
three times before they can do
anything.  In this case, you
should really try to focus
engage ing content higher up
in
the tree so that it's available
to the use er right away.  The
next thing is, we've heard a lot
that
they want to be able to get to
all of their media content while
they're inside the car so we're
working on ways for use ers to
browse through large amounts of
media content of course in a
safe manner.  So what does this
mean for the active offers?
What this mensas should not
, you should not trun
truncate your content   In this
case,
there's just two stations
because everything else got cut
off so let's try not to do that.
So the last thing I want to
talk about, content browse ing,
is
if your data is dynamic.  So,
for example, you're a media app
s a play list based
on where the use er is or the
traffic conditions, then when
that content changes you need to
us because we can update
the content browser through the
use er and you would do this
change call.    Now that we've
talked about media browse ing,
let's take a look at media
session.  So the media session
serves two purposes.  First, it
lets you send updates to us
about playback stakes or meta
us to remote control playback
inside your media app.  So here
we have our media browse er
service again.  This time, let's
method.  Inside of on create, we
sub stantiate -- sub
substantiate a
media browse er service.  This
is
important because when Android
Auto connects through your media
reTrevors the session token and
creates a media playback which
is then used to handle playback
and receive updates.
Also there is the media
session playback which you will
implement to handle playback
events from Android Auto.  We'll
the next slide.  And finally,
remember, when everything is
done, release the immediate Yay
session
media session.
This frees up any system
resources and tells Android Auto
that you're done playing so we
can clean up any left over UI
elements.
So here's an example of our
to handle various
playback events.  You override
them as you need, so, for
example, if your app is a stream
you don't need the on script to
next button because that doesn't
that as an implementation.  So,
in case of a playback or on
resume, you should check
if your
media session is active.  If
it's not, set it to active and
that shows Android Auto that you
method is the media ID.  This
method is invoke ed when a use
er go
goes through the content, clicks
This method will be invoke ed
and
this media ID will be patched in
in.  This media ID is the same
you have passed to us, so you
can imagine the media ID should
be unique and it should be
persistent so you can find the
right ID when the use er kicks
on
it.
A note about voice support.
So if you want your app to
command through voice,
like play jazz on my media app.
You'll first need to specify an
intent filter inside your
manifest filter.  This basically
tells us that you are able to
handle playback from surge.  So
when the use er uses this
command,
the on play from surge will be
invoke ed.  This the execute a
query, so if the query is empty,
you should first try to play
something back.  Because this
tells the use er that your app
is
response ive and that their
action
has taken place.  If the query
is valid, we'll pass the
information such as artist oral
bum name.  And
finally, if you
can't find the song, just tell
the use er that your app is
response ive.
No further questions let's
look at some of the updates that
can send over to
Android Auto.  First of all,
there's the metadata, that
contains things like album art.
the album art can show up as a
background image of maybe a
15-
15-inch screen.  In this case,
resolution is really important.
You can send that to us in two
ways, a URI.  I recommend a URI
because it scales down the bit m
map to 23 by 23 so if you want a
high resolution image, the URI
is the way to go.  So the other
stake that you can send us is
the playback stake.
This tells us things like,
if your app is playing, if it  a
nd actions that it can   If it
can skip forward,
if it's stopped, and also tells
us the playback position.  How
far along in the song you're
currently playing.  A couple of
tips here.  Don't send us a
playback stay change every
thing that is
changing is the playback
position because we don't use
this value to update the
progress bar instead of our
media app.  In fact, you're just
ignore ing these updates.
On a similar note, if your
s actually stopped, don't
send playback notes unless
they're actually changing
because again, you're just
ignore ing them and you're
taming
the system -- taxing the system.
Finally, I want to talk about
the buffer.  You should send us
a state right away because then
we can tell the use er that the
track is being downloaded
because if you don't do that,
your UI will seem somewhat un
unresponse ive.  And with that,
I
will hand it over to Vincent for
ations.
>> VINCENT MO: Thanks, Victor
(Applause)
hi, everyone.  My name is
Vincent and I'm a manager on the
Android Auto team.  So with the
Android Auto, we want use ers to
accustomed to in the car.
It's also important that the use
optimize ed
optimize ed.  To be honest, this
Auto has undergone extensive ive
study ies
study ies, driver distraction
study ies where glance time,
cognitive load, and performance
are all factored in.  As you can
-- this isn't something that we
think every media app can get
right.  In the end, we thought
it was best for the developers
to have an so developers can
folk s us on making your app
great knowing Android Auto will
provide a safe and pleasant
experience.  In this case, I'll
guide you through how you can
easily customer          customi
ze your app.
These controls are Android
Auto and laid  out differently d
epending  and
conditions that Android Auto is
running in.  For example, I look
different on the phone screen
than audio control cards on the
car screen and also looks
different in night mode and day
mode.  Again, this isn't
something that your app will
need to be concerned about since
Android Auto will handle this
behind the scenes.  How do you
get your app to exercise the
appropriate controls for your
sneap in the media session
playback state, remember that
your app is actually already
update ing the playback state
for
the media session.  Set the
supported actions via the set
actions method in the playback
state builder.  The playback
state compact class if you look
into it has a define ed set of
media action constants like play
skip previous.  Let's look at
the action skip to next content
as an example.  Because it's
listed as a supported action,
Android Auto will surface the
button in the controls
controls panel.
When the use er interacts
with this button, the media call
back on skip to next API will
get invoke ed.  A few things to
keep in mind, remember to always
keep the actions up-to-date
based on the appropriate
playback that the use er might
be
in.  For example, if the use er
is
at the beginning of the play
list, it might be a good idea to
We also recommend that the use
er
reports all bugs so that the app
doesn't lose any functionality.
Now what if your media app
supports something that isn't in
thumbs up.
An action stream is very
specific to your app and as you
need for each custom action an
action label text, this may be
accessibility.  A drawable
reflex, this is shown in the
playback control.  Remember to
include transparency in it and
we also recommend using SPG so
we can properly display it, and
lastly there is also an extras
bundle that is optional.
So when the use er
interacts
with the playback control, the
on session action of your media
gets invoke ed.  This is  can
handle the actual
like action.  We also know
product branding is important to
you and we want your apps brand
branding to show through well in
Android Auto, is if your app
already uses the material color
extreme, Android Auto will show
these colors in the appropriate
places throughout our UI you can
also define an Android Auto
specific theme in your media app
when the next track is being
played, a notification with the
track name will be shown so be
sure to specify an icon in your
manifest so that your app's icon
is displayed.  So that's.  With
a few simple steps you can
customize your media app
to an
interface that works across
Android Auto.
Next I want to talk about
message ing.  We know that
staying
in touch with people that we
care about like friends and
very important to all us
regardless of whether
we're in the car or not.  It's
important that use ers can
access
this with minimum extractions
distractions
they can access on the road.  We
app
should be burdened with having
to deal with this so with
message ing weaver taken a
similar
approach.  We have an API to
extract out these things so that
you don't have to worry about
and focus on getting the message
This is just      just a recap
of how
message ing works as Paco demoed
earlier.  It's pretty straight
forward.  We have a notification
then there's a message ing card
that remains in the overview
screen.  The API is quite
simple
simple, actually built on top of
Android notifications, which is
something I'm sure your app is
already using.  So when an
income ing message arrives, your
will
notify Android of the
notification.  Now, if your
notification is extended with
car extender, Android Auto will
be able to receive the
notification and display the
notification to the user.
When the use er issues a
read
command via voice, a red pending
get sent back to your
app.  Similarly, when the use er
reply ies to the conversation, a
reply pending intent gets sent
back.  You get Android Auto to
recognize your app for message
ing
messaging, make sure you include
the notification usage in your
Android manifest.  Okay, so
let's dive into the part of
extending your notification with
The interesting part had a we
care about -- that we care about
One tip that I want to pass
on is, if your app is actually
checking to see if Android Auto
is present before extending the
notification, we recommend not
checking for the existence of
the Android Auto package since
that's not very reliable.
Instead, you can use the UI mode
is rub     running in car mode.
So let's look at the unread
would be useful to
define some definitions.  So a
ledge is essentially just a
short length of of text that
Android Auto will readout to the
use er.  It's best to not make
these messages too long.  A
conversation is a collection of
ed together in    in
some way.  Typically, messages
between user and another person
would be a conversation.
So, with that, and  e
ssentially just
a set of unread messages for a
particular conversation.  So,
what goes inside this unread
conversation?  You can pass any
conversation name.  This is the
text that gets appeared, that
gets presented to the use er
when
Android Auto presents an unread
message.  Obviously, you pass in
the actual messages.  There
might be more than one, and in
this case, when you set the time
stamp for these messages,
include the time stamp for the
most recent message.
There are
two rue     remaining ones.  The
read
pending intent and the reply
action that we'll dive into in
the next slides.
Also, there's a emergency
nly has an -- message that
only has an image, we recommend
usable all text so user doesn't
experience
a broken experience when using
back the message.  Also, please
do think about how this works
for group chats.  We recommend
actually just testing out the
flow and seeing if when the user
is reading back the message, if
it's a good user
experience.
Next
slide.
Next -- okay.  All right.
Okay.  So, the read pending
again, is pending intent Android
Auto sends back to
your message ing app when the
use er
has invoke ed a read action.
It's
create ing the read pending
intent
is pretty simple.  You create
the internet that you want
Android Auto to send back when
the user has completed a read
message.  The primary things to
highlight is, you just want to
set the action string that is to
this read action.
Be sure to set the component,
because we want this intent to
be complicity
schist        explicit.  This
way, it's
guarantee ed your app will get
the
pending intent.
And then lastly, put the
conversation ID as an extra and
the intents that you can later
check.  And once you have that,
then you can just wrap it in a
pending intent.  So, receiving
this pending -- this read
pending intent is pretty simple.
against the read message action
string that we define ed earlier
pending intent is sent back to
your app, the appropriate
receive er -- the appropriate
broadcast receive er is
invoke ed.
And in the on receive call back,
the intent, and handle the read
message and event.
So, the last part is the
reply action.  I'll kind of just
over this.  Again, this
is since when there is a reply
event, similar to the read
pending intent, you create an
intent with the appropriate
action string that is specific
for the reply message.  And then
you can wrap the intent with the
pending intent.  The remote
input object is just passed
along with the pending intent
that gets sent back to your app
which will store the actual
string, making up of the useer's
the broadcast receive er that
you've registered will get the
on receive call back, and then
you can extract the ID and then
the message reply.  One tip is,
when you get this, just don't
assume that the use er has read
any unread messages since the
use er can actually send reply
ies
out of band.
And then, like media, you
can also customize the look and
feel in this notification, the
extender object.  Again,
that was a simple way of making
your message ing apps support
Android Auto and next, I'm going
>> PACO GALANES: Hi. Thank
you, Vincent
(Applause)
Just wanted to conclude,
summarize in what I believe are
the main three takeaways of the
presentation.  The first one is
that Android is showing great
momentum in the number of cars
that are supporting Android
Auto
Auto.  The number of
application
applications that are already
running on the platform and also
the number of country ies where
it's already available.  The
second one is that we're
expand
expanding our regional platform
to give your applications
significantly more reach by
enable ing Android Auto on your
phone screen and four, bringing
the power of Android natively
into the car.  The last point,
still, the same interfaces will
work across all three surfaces.
Your application will run the
framework that is being tested
for this driver distraction.
Including voice integration to
power the most common tasks that
you can perform. next steps, if
you're
ready to start implementing, to
start integrating with the
platform, all the technical
details that we talked about
today are available on these
links.  Please join the
development -- the developer
group, Android Auto dev and if
you remember any link out
out of
this talk, developerandroid.com/
developerandroid.com/auto.  In
the mean time, if you have
questions, come talk to us.  The
sandbox is right behind the big
tent here and check out the cars
the concept car and all of the
other ones.  We also have phones
works.
If you have time and want
to give code ing a try, we also
have an Android Auto specific
code lab in the code lab section
section.  If you want to hear
from us in the future, sign up
for news at Android.com/auto.  I
don't think we have time for QA,
but again, come talk to us.
We're in the sandbox.  And I
don't want to really take any
more time of yours.  Please,
it's been a long day.  Go enjoy
the concert.  Go relax.  And
thank you very much(Presentation
ended at 8:49